hello everybody it is Monday February 6
and we are here H3 podcast is live we
are unstoppable we are unmovable nobody
will ever shut us down nobody will ever
stop us I will not be told what to do or
how to do it I am here I am proud I am
Ethan Klein you will never defeat me I
will never be stopped ever ever we're
doing it live
I'm not gonna ask what happened
yeah it's kind of the explanation's kind
of
I got banned a lot last year I already
got in trouble this year too
but I didn't get banned so that's kind
of a dub when you when you get back if
you when you get banned do you look at
it because you could look at it as an
opportunity because we all know that
being on the Internet is a terrible
thing to do so when you get banned or
it's a little part of you not like oh I
don't have to look at YouTube insta
whatever it is it's a little bit are you
happy about that well so when I get
banned I it's usually or it's always
been seven days no uploading on YouTube
that's the band I'm talking about seven
days a week and yeah of course there's a
there's a part of me that's like okay
well at least because I don't take
vacations I don't take time off we're
here five times a week that's a
lot Nobody Does it like that and I'll
have you know
Nobody Does it like that it's a lot I
mean they're very it's it's a silver
line and you're like okay yeah manned I
can spend more time I am I I I enjoy
in a sense my seven days off last time
you got banned what did you do with your
vacation
I think I made video YouTube videos you
made you made a video on my channel why
do you why do you think you are alive so
much what do you well you know first of
all let me introduce Our Guest here it's
uh Gekko therapy gecko
friend of the show he was on I you said
it was a year and a half ago that
surprised me I was on a year and a half
ago and I still while when I walk around
in the gecko costume people will still
be like oh you're from H3
that's incredible and we love the fans
for that yeah good people man thank you
for having me back out there yeah but so
therapy gecko towards the world
um as a wise Sage gecko who is uh loves
giving people advice do I have that
right I I I think I'm less of a like
because I don't know anything about the
universe more than any other person that
I like talking to people about their
lives and about stuff less than uh you
know like hey I'm going to I know the
episode is called solves your problems
no guarantees no guarantee we put in
parentheses no guarantees that's a great
that's a good that's a good money back
guarantee no refunds yeah well you know
us never ran any refunds but yeah I
don't I'm a crazy guy in a gecko costume
I like I like talking to people though
well you've had a good run since our
last uh
visit here on the podcast you've been
done you've done episodes with like uh
some big names uh who who are some of
the people you collaborated with I I had
my personal uh Heroes I had Tim
Heidecker on oh I saw that that's great
congratulations that was cool and how
did he do was he um oh he was great it
was so cool because you know he uh I
mean he's responsible for making like
all this crazy crazy stuff but he's just
a you know he's a nice guy nice just
normal human being yeah yeah I love that
about him well here we are we have
Collins already populating actually
we're doing it on Discord today so
members we're already lining them up
with fascinating riveting questions
we're asked too excited solve to
roommate on solve we will 100 solve your
problems with no uh basis with no room
for error well here's the thing there of
course there's no refunds how do you
refund someone's time if we don't help
you you literally just wasted your life
talking to two dudes it's not a way you
put yourself out there to try to talk to
us you maybe you because that's the
thing is it's less about advice and more
about you talked about it right you got
it out into the universe and that in and
of itself is a nice thing okay so
there's kind of there's no failure here
in the case of the callers
well what if it's a really dumb story
and I'm like I'm not into it and then I
hang up
um there's something for them to learn
from that experience I think okay yeah
okay God like can we talk about like the
political and economic state of the
world right now sure
we talk about what's going on with the
environment can we talk about I hope
every I hope all the trees
and all the people in all the countries
that are all doing stuff
are chill
and hanging out and vibing as well well
that's a brave stance to take and I
appreciate you you know putting the kid
out there with all the controversy I did
want to do some top of the show stuff I
want to get your opinion on some stuff
oh gosh oh you're on tour let me let me
promote you here thanks man yeah therapy
geckos on tour if you guys want
uh coming up in Los Angeles looks like
uh Phoenix Las Vegas Salt Lake City what
are these shows like uh so lots of shows
oh yeah I booked way too many you got a
busy year uh I go up on stage I
give a little Spiel and then I just I
bring Folks up from the audience and uh
talk to them I have no I have very
little material or anything planned uh
people like show up and they text a
phone number with like their name and
what they want to talk about and then
I'll go up and I'll be like uh can
Chelsea come to the stage and I'll talk
to Chelsea sounds like Oprah in a way in
a sense I guess a little bit like Oprah
alive it's like Oprah yes it's it's it's
it's a little it's a little Opry except
I'm not giving everyone cars
okay well have you considered that
no
well maybe these tickets would have been
sold out by now if you considered
something like that hey if I had but I'd
be sold out
okay fair enough not it's not in the
budget yet no but we're maybe getting
there yes so um well since you're here
maybe I'll get your take on
um
yes you know what dude should I let's
just get into the calls I feel like
let's just talk to people
because I have all this top of the show
stuff but I feel like I want to
therapize people talk to me let's verify
some folks how do you guys feel about
that are we feeling that whatever
wherever so the world takes us we can
save this stuff for Wednesday you know
what I mean whatever you like whatever
you like
let's
get right into it so let me check the
list here we've got
our wonderful callers
uh Vanessa
21 wonderful member thank you
they're 21 you they're having
issues on if they should invite their
relatives to their wedding or not let's
let's talk let's hear about it that is a
that's a you know
that's a big question when how long ago
was your wedding
my wedding was 10 years ago was was
there any like uh people who you were
like let's leave them out
well so my wedding was in Israel and uh
anyone that I would have wanted to leave
out would wouldn't have wanted to make
the trip anyway sure yeah did you
combine Birthright on your wedding
that would have been kind of that would
have been a nice cost saving thing but I
was live I was actually living there
yeah appreciate that though
okay let's talk to uh
wait her name's Venus okay she got the
Venus ebony names
but if her first name's Robina let's
talk to Venus all right let's talk to
Venus uh give me one second let me move
that Venus sounds a lot like penis I've
just occurred to me
that's that's the most I hope that's the
most controversial thing said
today today me too me too all right I'm
bringing in uh Venus right now one
second
okay uh Venus are you there
I see that you are muted can you unmute
your microphone please we got the best
oh there there you go inside
Hi how are you guys
the Venus before we get is that that's
your first name Venus yeah that's that's
my uh non-government name okay good yeah
respect keep the government out and
Emily is your government name
maybe maybe not okay okay fair enough
and you and your thoughts on Venus
actually sounds a lot like penis is that
an issue for you
no that's actually a really good thing
as like a double drag performer I have
like both like a masculine and feminine
performance it can be penis and Venus oh
we love that we love love love love that
all right Venus why don't you
tell us a little bit about your issues
and let's see if we can help you resolve
navigate
so I met my boyfriend three years ago on
Tinder it surprisingly worked out which
was a huge shock to me
um and uh we met a month before covid
began which was really super fun
um oh sorry go ahead Ethan I can't hear
you on this end oh he didn't say
anything
oh I might be behind my apologies
um so basically his
parents did something very not nice and
uh I basically would take him early from
his house
and
um
they got really mad at me so I made a
tick tock about it because I was a
dumbass 18 year old and thought that my
view was small
foreign
and she's been really really upset ever
since even though I apologize and you
know that kind of was like it for me
whatever and then one time she
um and this is his mom she told him she
he goes you know what you're saying is
really affecting her negative flu and
you know she feels you know depressed
and she and she goes well why would you
want to be with someone like that for
the rest of your life
[Music]
um
okay
I want to back up a little bit we're
gonna need some details about yes about
what they did first of all is that a
good place to start yeah if you're cool
if you're cool with sharing it Mom you
when I'm talking on the phone you're
gonna have to give me a sec oh wait
what's going on there oh my mom's just
delivering a package to me
you live with your mom yeah I I'm a you
know a young yeah you're young I get it
did you did you run this issue by by her
as well oh my yeah they they they know
they know about uh oh Mom they're on the
screen right there but can your mom say
hi to us or no Mom you want to say hi hi
guys how's it going hey Mom hi Mom
she's probably aware of this issue we're
about to take on yeah I wanna I wanna
hear her I want to hear the whole issue
first but then I'd love to hear your
mom's take after we get is your mom
available
not like single I mean like available
for the phone call sorry
um I can do that yeah she can yeah
we're talking about uh someone's uh or
my my relationship and the current
issues we're having with them the
parents oh
no no
let me just put something out there
the first time you put this on Tick Tock
and that was the root of your troubles
is it possible but doing this call live
but also probably create a further riff
or you know
when you said Emily I was like cam
but it's okay we're we're going football
so we're 100 out there
my yeah but we're gonna keep my name
Venus Venus Venus so are you sure you
want to do this I'll give you that out
okay I'm gonna say I'm Venus and I'm
from Canada
so so Venus from Canada what um so by
the way with the with the wedding is it
like you're not sure whether to invite
your boyfriend's mom
both parents both the parents so when
you talk to your boyfriend about this
whole situation what what was his take
is that causing like uh some conflict
between you guys you know like after
three years we're both kind of like over
it like you know I've apologized and you
know I've I I feel and I hope that I've
put a lot of effort into trying to
redeem the relationship
um but I just feel like it's going
nowhere and you know it's it's painful
not having a relationship with you know
uh your like your step or not step
family you know their parents yeah
in-laws and stuff like that we must go
back to the Genesis of this issue uh we
we have to understand
the conf the birth of this conflict
Okay so
this was like week two or three and to
covet like nobody nobody knew what was
going on really however we both like
both of both of us did not go outside at
all and you know he was feeling upset
that he couldn't come with me and he had
an argument with his parents and you
know I don't like to inject into other
people's and other parents arguments
except when someone punches a hole in
the door
that that was like is that a metaphor
no that's dead ass okay
that's dead ass it sounds like a
metaphor is dead ass a metaphor no dead
ass is like straight up like straight
down okay yeah like no I don't know what
that meant so the so sub so so correct
me if I'm wrong I'm trying to parse the
information here
you went out during covet he wanted to
come with you they got an argument that
resulted in no no no his mom or dad
punching a hole in the wall he wanted to
I hadn't gone out he hadn't gone out he
wanted to come over for like a couple
hours at my house stay at my house just
us two hanging out okay okay actually I
see and and the resulting argument ended
up with the one of his parents punching
a hole in the wall yes okay that that
that's definitely some kind of anger
issue going on back there for sure
is that is that the the sort of extent
of what the initial thing was about yeah
there's something missing is there
anything missing that's it yeah that
that was basically it I mean well why
did that
I feel there's something missing from
this
well look from what you told us I mean
if we're gonna if we're gonna be in the
future
with where the wedding is can can I hear
just a little bit like I know that this
happened a while ago what is your
relationship with them like today
um so I have not seen them since
Halloween Halloween I said hi and that
was and that was about it I need to
understand why was punching a hole in
the wall so problematic to you
um
it scared me well were you there
I was FaceTiming him at that time okay
so you saw it on the screen and that
scared you yeah yeah and you know nobody
wants to
see someone or hear someone potentially
like I didn't know if it was gonna
escalate further sorry yeah
the hole in the wall just I I think is
representing just a general like
expression of of uh the boyfriend's
parents like anger maybe but again
are you afraid that they're gonna come
to your wedding and like punch a cake or
like also kind of act out let me ask you
this to probe further she said no sorry
have they hit have they hit him before
hmm
um
I now I don't wanna I don't know
okay I'm reading between the lines and
on the call was your boyfriend scared
yes I see I see
um what is his relationship with like
with them
nowadays um you know they're pretty
close it's just like you know how you
like you have you know how Ethan you
have that t word that you don't bring up
yes
I'm Caleb's like we just don't talk
about the parents because it you know
it makes both of us kind of just a
little bit more sensitive because you
know luckily my mom is really really
kind to him and we he stays over a lot
he's like
yeah it's awesome so here's here's what
I'm gonna tell you
families are complicated and listen
what's happened to him in his life I
don't have the whole backstory you guys
are young you know what I mean there's
going to be a time in your life where
you'll be able to move out and be on
your by yourselves without the influence
of anyone else but I will say this
and you tell me what you think I'm
putting this out there I think
that
you should invite them because you can't
go back and reinvite them you know what
I mean like invite them
in the hopes that you know some
something
you're able to resolve this somehow
amicably in the future but I was I was
thinking a similar thing because I I
think there is something to be said
about the the path of least resistance
you know I mean again it'd be one thing
if you felt as though uh uh you know
they were going to come and punch
holes in the wall at the wedding
but if again there's something to be
said about avoid it because I feel like
with these people's anger issues like if
they don't if if they're not invited to
the wedding it might Bubble Up more yeah
but then I'm like well then but you
can't just have that as like a thing
hovering over your head like dictating
your actions the thing is he's still
there he's still part of their lives
right what is your boyfriend or your
fiancee or what I'm not here's what he
thinks yeah does he want to invite them
he well he he's kind of on board with me
but my mom also is that if it's okay she
would like to say something yes please I
would love to hear from from your mom so
my take on this is invite them and if
they choose not to come that's on them
but she did the right thing by inviting
them your mom your mom has it all
figured out Venus
she's a wise woman and I want to get her
mom a gecko cost yeah she's a wise woman
and I'll tell you what I got a good
feeling about that Mom of yours
you know it's you know it's Jewish mom
things you get it
can I talk to your mom is she there
what's your mom's name or give me an
alias so that the
um Sam Sam okay
Sam I don't know why I get this feeling
but are you single
no okay because there was no mention of
the dads oh sure sure what's your
relationship like yeah what's the step
with your with your husband yeah you
guys have a solid thing yeah for sure
what was your wedding like sorry I was
just watching milk Manor on Sunday and I
just been possessed by
by uh all kinds of weird thoughts we um
we actually elope in Scotland because my
mother-in-law tried to take over my
wedding so yeah
so I I get where she's coming from
uh to all this to say Emily Venus it
sounds like you have uh good folks in
your life you know what I'm saying so I
think a couple of uh looming bad apples
shouldn't you know take away from the
fact that it sounds like you have a life
filled with love and a cool mom and uh a
cool name too
dive into all that totally not Emily
totally Venus no I I who's Emily for you
who's Emily is a good question I never
heard I don't even know why I'm saying
it mom um what G is your mom a good cook
what is her specialty oh does she have a
special dish she's the she's one of the
best cooks ever what's her what's her
her dish yeah
there's a lot of them right now I'm
really liking her quiche
um is really good um
piece is like an egg cheese based kind
of pie with stuff in there do I have
that right yeah eggs I caught egg pie
with like meat in it
all right listen y'all
y'all
got it figured out invite them
but
is your dad a big guy can you throw down
he's not gonna like the way you laughed
about that
well you should you should invite Ethan
and he can be The Bodyguard instead oh
yeah Ethan if you ever do need uh any
contacts into the drag World let me know
okay that's great thank you yeah I'd
love to come to the wedding but I'm not
allowed in Canada I was arrested for
trafficking oh you know what that is
correct
95. I'm learning so much about you yeah
I'm not allowed anyway guys thank you so
much we appreciate it keep those
Keisha's coming mom and Venus totally
not Emily
have a great wedding
thank you guys so much peace and love
love you guys so much what's your life
with your mom I think we just I think we
just solved the case
her mom did we didn't do anything but uh
yeah her mom her mom kind of got ahead
of that yeah I think he may have opened
up a case or two
well you know what she was yeah yeah
hopefully they don't hear this yeah it's
good it's okay yeah nobody watches this
show that was a warm-up yeah you're
right nobody watches this show my how
are my relationship with my parents no
well you it's been an extent it's an
extensive topic of conversation on this
show but overall good okay good with
some asterisks what what are the Astra I
assume we've talked about them before
but well
how it's like I want to give my dad a
break at this point
is Malaga is a very sweet lady and she's
very beloved by this community his dad
has respect but he's part of the show
he's you know very pervy and which I
think he would read he you know he's
pervy he goes to Dodger games and stabs
beach balls
really what do you think happened to him
to make him like that well I know and
it's it's it's it's you know he he was
abandoned by his father when he was like
five very tragic and awful yeah and in
the role of a lifetime Gary
his name's Gary
spooky okay another uh
spooky should I say their name or what's
going on here because this has like
spooky and then another real name that
was just a uh why don't we just use
their their screen names to just play it
use their birth names
they're screaming I said the opposite of
that spooky I don't know how you heard
that 27. spooky bring on spooky 27 they
recently had a family member diagnosed
with breast cancer
okay spooky uh hold on one second you
said you said we had a lot of whimsical
calls this is not Whimsical actually in
fact
you want to break it up maybe we come
back to Spooky after a little bit more
of a lighthearted one I feel like we are
I feel like we already got Spooky's
hopes up to talk to us well
it's up to you
let's let's give him let's give him a
chat you know what I mean okay bring it
in spooky standby sometimes things that
like start off uh heavy they they end up
being light
sorry I'm just
spooky you're there I'm bringing them in
right now spooky okay no I have a
question already for The Spook uh hello
spooky there spooky do you think spooky
I can I can find something else to
tickle your brains with schmooky no no
no no no
I want to ask you a question right off
the bat
you have a family member dying of cancer
are you afraid of being spooked by them
after they die
no I I honestly
I have really high hopes for it but uh
you can make jokes like this I don't
want people I know the comments are
gonna say some but it's fine you
can make comments like that
um and uh by the way I thought the Cutie
Cinderella video was funny but you know
it's okay
um no comment yeah no comment uh but she
just got diagnosed a week ago so she's
not really to me she looks fine like
she's not like
under effects of Kim or anything like
that right now like so she's good and we
caught her early the only thing I wanted
to ask like how do you like I know your
mom a few years ago she got she had a
problem with her heart I just want to
know how how you coped with it and like
how like how that affected you because
she's really important to me you know I
only have one brother that's his wife
they've been together for 10 years she
just had two kids one is two one is one
damn and um
she for a long time they wanted kids and
with treatment like you guys and you and
here they did a lot of treatment and
they unfortunately were able to have two
kids like right like back to back
um
I mean fortunately okay just making sure
turning over every stone you know what I
mean spooky yeah yeah yeah and
um
you know it's just a lot it's like we
hoped for her to have these kids and
then all of a sudden like she also now
now we're dealing with this it's like a
lot you know all in like
spooky what do you um what does your mom
like what do you know about her how much
do you know about her mom it's my it's
my uh it's my sister-in-law oh my sister
your sister-in-law okay do you have a
close relationship with her
yeah I've known her ever since she's
been dating my brother and they got
married you know okay
she's like another sister I mean I've
known her for forever well you know how
do you cope with it the real the let's
first of all hope she's gonna be okay
right you guys caught up early and
that's good she she she's gonna get
really good medical care she works in
the hospitals she's a nurse so my advice
to you as the uncle and brother-in-law
and brother
as hard as it is on you it's going to be
10 to a billion times harder on the kids
and on your brother so just be there to
support them as much as possible that's
my advice to you
yeah I appreciate that
um but yeah also there's some good
experimental drugs coming out of like
Mexico that you can get black market
those kind of stuff yeah so I think I
saw someone like uh
uh whatever that Chinese website is I
forget
um have you been browsing online looking
for these drugs oh yeah yeah it's like
that that black cell that they used for
skin cancer
that like rots away at your skin from
melanomas yeah I've been looking up
stuff like that
yeah I was making a joke I don't know
what the that is bro but please
don't take it
yeah I don't know what that spooky but
yeah just you know what I mean look
after your fam dude how do you cope with
the pain of loss there's no coping you
just gotta you just gotta live through
it did you uh uh I once saw somebody uh
tweeted at Norm Macdonald rest in peace
asking for advice about this thing and
and Norm tweeted back and said kind of
the most beautiful thing I think I've
ever heard about like uh grief and loss
he said something like take all the love
that you have for this person and just
give it freely to everyone you meet wow
you know you gotta take uh whatever kind
of negative stuff's going on in in this
realm
transmute it into positive vibes and
you know that is actually really
sprinkle it out onto the Universe I love
that yeah when I saw that it blew my
mind to the goat
but hopefully not ripped here uh
sister-in-law yeah that would be pretty
bad thank you spooky you take care okay
stay off the black market uh shout out
to Erica she's a huge friend of yours
and your wife she buys all your merch
yeah Erica I I love your show and uh
thanks we love your show and uh thank
you so much yeah
have you been through the Bruce's
birthday was like last week oh thanks
bro yeah his birthday was on the second
you remembered thanks man one year old
he is yeah he just turned one we had a
really nice party he had chocolate cake
for the first time and he got ela's mom
is with us and she's like this insane
Baker she made like the almost off the
wall chocolate cake and he took a whole
piece of chocolate cake this is after
dinner this boy was not hungry and just
went he just ate so much freaking cake
he's very happy I have pictures of it
actually maybe I can pull him up but uh
thank you spooky thanks spooky
how is um How is how's domestic life for
you
it's great good you know I love it I
always my dream before I actually was
successful in any way was to become a
stay-at-home dad really I said to my I
told Eli
when we first met I would be very happy
to just
you support me and I do nothing that's
not really what you do at home though
well not you have to do stuff you change
diapers and no being at home is the
hardest freaking job in the world has
the baby ever pissed on your face
um I think Gap actually it has happened
once okay Theodore peed on my face when
he was a kid but Bruce actually I don't
think has ever peed on me
I wonder what that says about them like
as the people
that they'll turn into you know
we'll find out to find out
very good
um
another pseudonym it sounds like oh okay
ing
e
they says uh she doesn't know how to
talk to her boyfriend
this is exciting now here's a good topic
yes I would love to talk about this I
just went to uh I went to AVN recently
you know what that is yeah the avian
Expo uh adult video game yes I learned a
lot about I learned a lot about
pornography
what was the most interesting factoid
well I don't know I think I win maybe I
went in with like preconceived notions
about it everyone there was a very kind
person exploding milk did you see lots
of titties and actually no I
thought I I thought I was gonna be like
people having sex everywhere but uh very
strict very professional very
professional very strict no no boobs
rule
so you were just kind of you you were
shocked by the nice and professional
nature of the folks there yeah I guess
you go in with an idea of it like being
like some crazy like sex party thing but
it was just a bunch of folks uh it was
like a trade show
okay well
um Oni are you with us no in fact we
might have to come back to this one
because it looks like they may have hung
up no no I'm trying to track them down
right now um so maybe we can we can loop
back to this one let me uh
it's here I just found their account let
me okay this one's actually good let's
talk to Bryce 24 he says he's in a
long-term uh relationship but he feels
like his partner doesn't enjoy sexual
intercourse oh yeah this is a very
interesting topic sorry about this
let's talk to Bryce and hopefully come
back to Oni mm-hmm
dig up Bryce give me one second yes so
um do you make any friends at the adult
I I made friends with this uh I made
friends with a male porn star guy and I
like I made some joke to him about like
doing porn in the Gekko costume and he
when he but because that's like his
world he didn't register to him as a
joke he was very much like oh yeah you
could they've done worse than doing that
I've seen weird ass porn bro all right
I've got Bryce and a gecko costume ask
ask me on the on the on the bottom half
of this uh this gecko endeavor
all right would you do your adult life
I look as a very dad joke my goodness I
had to do it twice all right I'm
bringing in Bryce right now Bryce uh
Bryce are you there
I I am here there's Bryce Bryce my boy
what is up Ethan Lyle big fan of both of
y'all oh thanks I'm a big fan of you
Bryce Chris what's going on let's just
get let's get right into it let's get
right into it
um I've been in a relationship it's
going to be six years in March
and um we have intercourse like a lot of
relationships nice and sick
that's epic bro
and here's the thing though
um she is like she's perfect she is uh I
took her virginity she was a very timid
girl
um and she's like the most perfect
person ever but
I feel like she does not enjoy
intercourse in the way that I do I feel
like she more so does it because I want
it does that make sense it does yeah it
does
have you guys like had that conversation
like have you told her that that's how
you you your read of the situation yes I
I and I I tell her that and then she she
denies it of course and maybe it's just
my insecurities like thinking that I'm
not doing a good enough job or something
but I don't know I just have always felt
like it's more so her doing it for me
than doing it for herself and I'm always
the one that takes initiative and
whatnot let me ask you this
do you think if looking back did she
enjoy it more in the beginning of your
relationship or has it always been the
same note
well here's the thing I'll tell you this
for We Were Young when we first met like
we were like 19 and when we had sex it
was like all the time in the car just
you know college student stuff and she
never really finished back then
she's never she's she's a woman that
that cannot or as far as you know you
didn't for like the first year we just
never focused on it it was more so about
time you know like let's get it done let
me finish no no no no let me rephrase
that yeah that's fin that means you're
coming that's about that means it's
about when you come yes yes
um so if you have you like talked to her
about like Hey listen what what could I
do to make this experience more
enjoyable for you
um yes we've we've talked about that and
I guess maybe I maybe I don't understand
her perspective but she has told me that
it it is more so about like emotional
intimacy
um when it comes to that and it's it's
difficult for me because as a guy it's
like you know it's really just
I need to rub it out you know what I'm
saying there's a there's an interesting
thing happening here yeah
so the first year you guys were having
sex all the time
yeah but then you're talking about the
second year she started to experience an
orgasm or or tell me kind of yeah we we
started um we started living together
and so it was more so like we had more
time and uh we could talk about those
things you know you get more comfortable
in the relationship and whatnot but even
so uh there have been times where like I
feel like she maybe even faked it just
you know and okay was there ever a point
in your relationship where you feel she
was sexually gratified or sexually
satisfied
uh yes very sparingly if if you just so
this has been something you've been
insecure about for a long time oh yeah
almost like the whole relationship yeah
and she she can like when you try to
bring it up she she completely says that
she doesn't there's nothing wrong and
like there's no inkling of a thing that
she would like you to do or or any I'm
more curious about like her response
when you bring this up to her what does
she say yeah it's just always oh I do
enjoy it even if that's the thing I have
always Associated finishing with
enjoying it she said well she said even
if what even if she doesn't finish she
she enjoys doing it and letting me
finish have you tried to have you gone
in like having sex with her being like
this I'm gonna try my best this one this
one's for her have you gone into it like
okay okay how does that go
I think it goes It goes well but again
that insecurity's still there like while
I'm doing it that she's that she doesn't
really want to be there right exactly
right and um what what sexual act makes
her finish because some women's bodies
are very different some women can finish
through you know normal intercourse
penetration a lot of women can only
finish through like direct stimulation
hand movements mouth movement you know
what I'm saying without getting too
graphic of course
yeah it's it's it's what it really is
lots of uh lots of
oral I guess beforehand and then
switching and putting in the work yeah
and stimulating with my hands on other
parts while I'm penetrating and you know
okay okay okay trying not to calm myself
you know and
do you have a problem with premature
ejaculating
uh it's not premature but it is we've
we're so comfortable with each other
that my body because when we first
started you know doing it I I feel like
I was so nervous that I wasn't finishing
and now we are so comfortable together
that I can on a flip of a dime just you
know let it rip okay can I ask you this
you you you talked to her and she was
like okay for me not farting uh Bryce
you said she said that for her it's
about the emotional aspect of it right
yeah have you talked to her about like
okay how can I best serve that candles
um we've talked a little bit about it I
guess that's that's that's a place where
I can improve is talking more about what
that means to her she literally
sometimes has told me that like she
enjoys talking and being emotional like
speaking to each other during the
Intercourse like that helps that's kind
of I don't know it's weird for me I
guess I I have an observation to make
please you strike me as a guy who
you've described coming as letting it
rip you've said that you can come in
three seconds you even described a whole
first year of having sex with her where
the focus was on time or as I interpret
that as you busting and then the
interaction being over right what I'm
I'm seeing you as a guy who's very
mechanical he wants to get him and get
it done
I'm seeing your girlfriend as somebody
who's very emotional with sex and this
is not uncommon some women and men it
really you know they it is a very
emotional experience for them and so I
think you need to be extraordinarily
mindful of what sex means to her it
means
it means like hanging out a little bit
beforehand having a
some snuggling lots of kissing you know
talking about stuff like a build up I'm
not talking about you can't be getting
in there and then um you know letting it
rip and then complaining should enjoy
the sex you know what I mean yeah
no yeah because she's not she doesn't
like me as someone who's real freaky
who's trying to get all weird in the
bedroom it sounds to me like she wants
to have an emotional connection and that
to her is the most important thing about
sex
I think you're absolutely right I think
I need to reevaluate my own relationship
to uh quote letting it rip absolutely
yeah that's
yeah you gotta you gotta let it rip
emotionally oh you gotta come beautiful
words out of your mouth into her ear
vagina
found that for that one that's beautiful
thank you guys
is there anything else we can well I
would also recommend couples therapy to
you guys because I'm thinking that too
it sounds like you guys are in love it
sounds like you adore her and it sounds
like she's been with you for six years
and you're not even making her you're
not even sexually gratifying her so
she's gotta like you too right yeah
right so so I recommend
go to counseling because that's a great
place to work out these kind of deep
emotional issues because you know what
in a case of someone like that
without knowing anything about your
girlfriend who I'm sure is lovely
there could be some kind of sexual
trauma in her past I don't know if
that's uh presumptuous but there could
be something that makes her
turn off during like these quick or it's
just turned off a sexual part of our
brain and um I don't know but I'm saying
that you know sex is such a
I think we're discovering more that sex
is such a
personal and powerful and emotional
thing and everybody is so different in
how they experience
sexual gratification or excitement that
um
we can no longer just assume that people
are going to have the same expectations
as us in a sexual encounter
um so different but I look it sounds I
mean look I mean even the fact that
they're calling us right now and that
you have because a lot of people will
say this like they'll call in and talk
about this and I'll be like did you talk
to them about it and they'll be like no
I haven't yet yeah so even the fact that
you did that I like just see I mean
you're trying this is a lot so
um I agree
but also you know having that level of
insecurity is also not good in a
relationship you want to be fully there
you want to be fully present with her
and so when she tells you you know I'm
fine you know you want to be able to
believe her right and so you guys I do
think it's important to get through this
um and I do think you guys can get
through this
but I think you gotta probably go into
the acts more about like
what does she do make it all about her
right because at the end of the day you
want to feel you want to feel that she's
satisfied you don't want to feel
insecure follow her lead follow her cues
don't listen to your you know what
I mean just follow her just listen to
her body what she's saying what what she
seems to like and maybe
um let her have her way just let her
have her way
was that from that's Jordan Peterson
play the whole thing for me um Sam yeah
I was here this is from Jordan Peterson
standby standby standby doing it
upstairs so my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bay I saw my maternal
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed this at my face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
finally unwilling to hurt her or
interfere with her any further I let her
have her way
she stroked my face with the brush
gently and said like a child
that's really dark
it certainly something I did it sounds
like something happened to him
he will yeah potentially I mean he is
really dysfunctional so that that
definitely Rings true to me well caller
how was that helpful yeah did the good
question oh yeah thank you thank you
guys so much okay good is there anything
else that you want to say to the people
of the computer before we go
um uh thank you for talking to me about
this I have more questions oh you have
more questions it's your shot I want to
let you do your thing no I I listen
we're on the same wavelength here but
okay things have you have you guys ever
done like uh explore different kinds of
uh sexual I don't wanna maybe not
fantasies but like I don't know have you
guys ever you guys just go in there and
do it missionary like what's the extent
of your guys's exploration well
fantasies
um we we've tried some stuff in the past
like you know role play uh or whatnot
but um I feel like it always just comes
back to uh you know as long as we're
trying different positions and I don't
know trying to keep it interesting
um it works
when you say role play what kind of role
play are we talking about
yeah we can we can get our costumes
involved well here's the thing we're
both theater kids shout out Olivia
perfect so we uh I mean there's a time
where like I don't know maybe she
pretended she was a stripper and I was
the client oh thank God have you okay I
I I I'm who's I guarantee that's not her
who has she ever suggested a role play
or is it typically
um that was literally like year two of
the relationship bro you are
this woman is a saint bro she's got it
figured out have you has she ever
suggested a role player is it all from
your imagination
it's it's my Dark Twisted Fantasy again
hey what was her stripper named
Cherry I don't know no I'm just right
well you are depressed My Beautiful Dark
Twisted Fantasy
has she ever proposed a role play
no of course not Ethan would you ask her
to and she's like I don't know
no no no it is like we were had such a
weird relationship to sex you know
meeting at 19 years old that we were
kind of nervous to like bring well now
you've been together for six years so
yeah yeah I guess we could reopen the
conversation but you never asked her if
you wanted if she wanted to do one I
have I have I think you know what she
might like as a role play is oh you role
play that you're on your first date and
you don't know anything about her
and so now and so now it's and so this
is all this is what she just wants she's
like I want you get the chance to you
ask her questions what do you do for
work what's your life like I think that
could be fun also you could role play as
a guy who's taking her out on a date
yeah feel like a nice romantic dinner
and then you come home you put on some
music this is role-playing of course and
then um you kind of maybe or maybe you
can cook her a meal you know what I mean
just talk with her a little bit get lost
in her eyes then all of a sudden
you make the move you go for the kiss
then I let her rip and then you come in
your pants
and then you take off the VR goggles
but I am seeing a picture if I can be
frank with you uh where it seems like
your pursuit of sexual Endeavors seems
very much centered around your needs and
desires
sure yeah
uh but I I will say it sounds like um I
said this already but you know I'm glad
I'm glad to hear that you're it seems
seems as though have evolved from that
and are now trying so you care keep
doing that you know yeah absolutely I've
I've bought like toys and stuff for her
like stuff does she use them
we have yeah together we did them
together
yeah good yeah it's a decent start you
ever use one of those giant back
massagers bro that look like power
rocket I know dude
back in the day I mean not to get too
graphic but um go ahead that uh that was
like all we had and it was like that
thing started up like a semi truck you
know that thing was it's not for
everybody because that thing is
nuts dude yeah did that work on her or
no
oh yeah but here's the thing you could
not put it directly on it would like
destroy it's too much
right it's like a Jackhammer
dude yeah absolutely I remember when I
first started like masturbating as like
a little like I was like a like a little
like I was like well I was like I
remember I was 10 and I had one of those
like massager things and I put it on my
penis and then but I could there was
nothing happening so it just turned red
God
it didn't feel good then why'd you do it
no it felt good but it was like you know
when you're like there was no I couldn't
come back then so my dick turning red
was my version of coming
there was no gas in the tank
you know so I hope this call was helpful
for you
absolutely yeah bro go romancer dude
yeah let let her remind her why she's
she fell in love with you
absolutely thank you guys of course get
out there and get and keep that girl bro
let it rip emotionally like you said it
rip emotionally that's the motto and
it's true because maybe sex just isn't
that important to her and she and the
closeness is what she likes so give her
that
I met a guy who has been in all of their
like they have all these like taking a
virgin to the club videos I met the guy
who what happens when you bring a virgin
to the club I don't I haven't seen
anybody rip
apparently in his pants
Bryce uh he just left although I'm sure
he'll he'll hear the uh goodbye I think
you know what the final thing for Bryce
I think we nailed it I think we did a
good job with Brian
it's this is a young man he's only got
24. yeah well it's a hard thing to like
uh when I when there's like insecurity
uh yeah you know it's a hard thing like
how much can you uh uh help the person
you're with how much can you help their
insecurity because battling and security
is such a personal thing you know you
have to kind of run a little bit you
don't whenever you feel insecure in a
relationship it's the worst so you
definitely want to get on top of the car
because uh like more validation from
other people doesn't is not the key to
solving your insecurity so you Val it's
like it's it's tough you know you have
to do it on your own
well that's probably a lot of what was
going to lead to on the road of cheating
or infidelity is that if you're feeling
insecure or unfulfilled in some way
emotional it's emotionally is what's
going to cause people to cheat in my
opinion unless you're just a straight up
sex addict because
You're Gonna Want to fill that emotional
hole and it's going to feel really good
for you to do that Until you realize
what a mistake you made but yeah I'm
with some like I'm cheating right
like I'm being a scumbag who is that
that's keemstar you have so much lore go
ahead and play play the one of um yo bro
I'm at this high school girl that I was
hot as tonight he's 40. tonight and
play the other one the recent one what
is this from he has a show
do I play the recent one Jeff you know
what I'm talking about
uh about the 16. I don't have that one
oh my God Jesus you get the idea
can you pull that please yes
let's move it on oh did we get Oni back
uh I don't think so I sent them a
message too that sounded like a good one
yeah can I see what's going on sure you
see any good ones here you can pick the
next one here we have a lot of options
no no no
no no no I I how about how about um
Jeter Griffin
which number is that seven needs help
with being chronically online
it's very Broad
we like that one let's go let's talk to
Peter Jeter Griffin Jeter Griffin is uh
Family Guy ass sounding
right now
uh Mr Jeter I don't know exactly are you
there yeah hi
oh yo hi what's up cheater
what's up y'all just gonna get some
lunch how are you guys doing good what
so you say you're chronically online
what what are you chronically online
doing
pretty much taken someone chronically
online it's got a pretty shitty
interview gotta work yeah exactly
that's a very true point there uh
all right all right is that working that
sounds yeah you sound good
all right sorry I was connected to my
Bluetooth
you were connected to your Fitbit
yeah my Fitbit well I can certainly
understand why it was a poor connection
why are you what are you doing online so
much
you know the amount of time I think I
spend on your specific uh you know
Discord chat it's probably pretty bad
I don't really talk to much people like
really I don't know I guess I'm just
socially awkward just got scared but
like
I don't know like the only group chat
I'm in is definitely the general chat
and it's like so you're online you're
not like Doom scrolling I'm sure there's
a little bit of that but you're most of
the time is spent like chatting with
other folks
I guess sometimes when I when I get like
that confidence to do it is it does it
make you socially anxious even to have
like on like internet conversations
honestly yeah like I'll be honest like I
think um what it is is just really how
to carry a conversation without running
it into a wall you know what I mean am I
going to say this you're on that's great
you sound like right but I understand
there's a people you can it's easy to
hide it uh having the same thing you
sound very comfortable right now
oh well I don't know I guess it's like
kind of that thing I'm a musician so
when like you go on stage you kind of
just stop thinking you just kind of do
you know what do you know I guess
go ahead what was that
do you uh do you have a lot of like
friends on in real life
um well I mean I I did but I think after
the pandemic and all that kind of just
isolating myself it like now when I went
back to like the original friend groups
I have I feel like I'm just like
hey uh you know what I mean like you
neglect like like you were neglecting
them for so long so to re-enter would be
uh I guess so it's you know that
uncomfortable like hey how how how long
has it been how are you pal I don't know
the small talkies what gets you guys
lost you guys lost the connection uh
um what do you what do you do can I ask
what do you what do you do with your
life
oh well right now actually
um uh because I'm kind of in between
finding a job I I recently got into a
car accident where uh on the day of when
I was supposed to start a new job the
um you know ever since then it's just
been like a constant circle of just
applying I go on a couple interviews but
it's just you know not coming through
and so like you know besides that just
spending my time watching the podcast
I guess I am Doom scrolling because you
know I'm always on Twitter I'm always on
every single social media you know but I
don't know I think what I'm trying to
say is how brain rotted I feel you know
yeah oh yeah yeah it's probably not the
chronically online though it's probably
the fact that like you're unemployed
that automatically you know and I'm and
you're gonna find a job you know you're
gonna get there but that's gonna leave a
lot of free time I think what you're
feeling is not is probably a temporary
and I get this even when I have too much
free time I just feel bad yeah you have
Idle Hands you just feel like why am I
here on this Earth at this moment do you
ever you ever you ever like find your
when you have nothing to do you just go
into your habits like you were like find
yourself on the internet like you find
you're like oh I'm on Tick Tock this
wasn't even like like I didn't I didn't
even make the decision to pull out my
phone and go on the app I just found
like some muscle memory I think when the
detox gives you the you know the you've
been scrolling for a minute I've been
like that I hate that because it just
makes you're like bro and you don't
let you don't listen right you just
don't bad so what's what's the what's
the dream uh Jeter what's what's what's
the ideal life for you
well see um I just
I just I don't know I guess the main
thing is I just want to be comfortable
you know I feel like sure you know when
it comes to like a certain thing like
say like right now being in front like
not even though I'm not in front of a
lot of people but like you know talking
to you guys with people listening it's
like I get into this head space where
I'm not really thinking I'm just kind of
doing and I'm trying to translate that
into like just everyday life where I'm
not feeling like this weird pressure to
like you know I don't know this we like
I said the small talk I feel like I
can't I don't like that bullshitting
that I I want to like do you know what
you don't have to do it you don't have
like when you see your friends for the
first time in a while you can look look
them in the eyes and go how is your life
going you don't have to play a role of
some kind that you think you're like I
guess the thing is it's because I'm I'm
not that I'm introverted but I'm just
friends with extremely extroverted
people okay so with like I said like I
said since I isolated myself and I came
back they've always been like I'm not
gonna lie they're kind of like they're
still hanging out there in covet they're
still doing a lot of stuff I was just
staying inside you know hanging out with
my girlfriend or doing any of that you
have a girlfriend now when I try to go
on to the outside
you have a girlfriend
oh yeah bro you're fine
whoa yeah I mean
yeah I'm not really struggling on the
right I'm just saying bro like if I
assumed that you were like single as
just based on what you're saying
that's a huge thing you have resolved
there in your life
um I'll be honest like I said like when
I was younger I like I was a little
extrovert before the whole covet stuff I
was kind of like
you know chat it out or whatever and uh
uh yeah now you know you know
being recessive as hell I think you just
need a job bro you have too much free
time yeah that's my assessment I think
more more time where you can be with
people not on the computer is is always
it's always good of course it just also
sucks because like I said like since the
social media has brain rot in my brain
like if I'm in like a like a setting
where it's serious kind of like on the
the chestnut thing I kind of relate to
that my brain just kind of you know
yeah Play the song Zach first a mile
cheers
I recently played this song yeah over a
uh acquaintance of mine very nice girl
she was crying
[Music]
about something horrible that had
happened
and I played that oh oh oh oh oh and it
did not go well okay okay it was it was
a controversy I recently had well how
does it oh uh Jeter how does this tie
into what you were saying about
re-entering I'm just trying to explain
the Lord
you mentioned it so it ties in somehow
does that tie in yeah is it like is it
just an example of like your he
empathizes with me okay are those like
you're chronically online you're
speaking in you know lore of of podcasts
and memes and that's my language is
literally all like
we got wings and fish and stuff like
that it's like
do you do you you said you want to be do
you desire to
be offline like you really actually what
because look you don't have to go on a
hike bro
do you desire to be offline like there's
probably hiking trails near you
right well see that's the thing I do
everything alone like I do everything I
guess someone would do I go to shows
alone I go I sometimes go but I'm just
trying to like learn to just you know
not run conversations into a wall yeah I
guess I can do that by also getting a
job and being forced Let's uh what's
what's the last show you into alone
I actually saw this band called a king
gizzard and the lizard wizard I love
those guys are you serious bro did you
re did did you say that because you know
Dan's a Super Fan about it
uh you know Stu McKenzie that guy's the
goat you're no when you were at the
concert did you like did you try to talk
to anybody or were you keeping to
yourself
I mean uh not I mean I wasn't really
trying to talk to people I guess that's
true but I mean I would get into the pit
by myself I'd do stuff like that um did
you have a do you have a desire okay did
you have a desire to talk to people or
that you were afraid I mean honestly
looking at other people's groups and
they're all like having a good time
they're you know just sit like that I'm
just like you know what I wish I had
someone I can just invite to a show and
like let's just go you know but you're
at the show and there are people and
here's the thing if you I've thought
about this for my own thing if you put
yourself out to like if there's a group
of folks at a concert or something and
you're like hey guys how's it going and
you try to talk to them and they rebuff
you it's not that big of a deal you came
into the situation with good they don't
even know who you are you know that's
true it's just I hurt my own feelings a
lot like you know like well I don't know
I'll be honest with you I have a similar
issue if I go somewhere I'm not going
I'm not the type of guy who's going to
make friends but here's where you and I
differ I'm content
with not talking to anybody
that's why I was trying to wonder if you
are content just being like alone alone
or if you want to but I mean like I said
I think before pre-win because like I
said I'm I'm in a band with my one of my
really extroverted like friends and like
I wasn't in a man he has a girlfriend
you're living bro yeah well sure but
this I'm curious that makes it more
interesting because I'm curious what's
going on in your head that's making you
not I don't know I see that or dive into
that I am living but say if like if I do
a show I go on stage do my thing and
then once I'm off like everyone's saying
good job everyone's like oh so good set
but I'll just dip right after I'll be
like cheater I love you
let's just you know what I mean I mean
probably talk to a therapist or
something right well all these people
should talk to a real therapist well it
sounds like you're having some kind of
like um
social anxiety you know what I mean like
it might be it might be that you have
some kind of uh
some kind of issue that that uh
I think I'm just trying to get out of
this call to be honest we can tell we
can take another I know you didn't want
to say thank you Jeter thank you Jeter
appreciate you get off your phone throw
it into a river sometimes I don't know
how to get out of a call are you afraid
I know it's going too long and it's
getting boring and that no offense to
Jeter sure but I I there's a I have a
second sense to me where I'm like I
gotta get out of this I found that I
found it fascinating because I well it's
well because you were like oh well you
don't have a problem because you have
the relationship you're in a band but I
was like well that is makes the problem
more fascinating to me
I guess I sh I guess I I don't know
maybe let's do a poll so I can get a
sense did Ethan win the right thing or
should we have let it go
sometimes my intuition's wrong
people get mad with it
I will say when I take phone calls and
like do my walk-ups on my show and the
hardest thing is like knowing when to
end and then doing it well my thought
was that was that he kind of he started
to kind of start repeating himself and
at the same day
at the same time the man is in a band
he's got a girlfriend it's like it's
like
you are wrong you're fine bro what does
that sound bite from
I believe that one is Kenneth Copeland
is that right late again oh it's Kanye
okay oh okay now what okay so is that
it's fairly split but I have a slight
majority here what's going on in the
chat chat can we talk to the Chatters
that is not a talking to chatty no of
course we can talk to the chat we're
doing it live
that's too many people yeah it's kind of
hard to yeah yeah I mean no offense bro
I just think like yeah that's what it is
and I and I apologize I have to show you
well you can't I I have a show to do so
sometimes I go I just I and there was no
way out of it right no there was no
way to end that call gracefully
but I knew I had to do it so I apologies
you have not apologize for for you
looked at me like what's happening no no
no no
do we still have uh veto power you want
a uh didn't actually never mind
yeah and back part I mean never mind
yeah let him speak let them cook
I'm just gonna end it I'm gonna I like
Jeter personally I was happy to keep
that I love them but we
I was over it I'm sorry you know what
we've spent we've now spent we're gonna
get to a point where we actually spend
more time wondering if the call went on
too long then the call was long we'll
actually find a meta conversation much
more interesting too yeah I mean no it
is the hardest thing because you don't
look again the thing says solve your
problems but I mean all these are they
they they're I think these are nice like
jumping off point we may have
exacerbated his problem in this case
made him more insecure or at least me I
don't know I think we gave him something
to think about maybe I don't know uh so
Oni is this person coming back or no
they haven't all right
I go to the aquarium alone I can stare
at one fish for three hours make a deep
connection
that's pretty weird dude
let's see um
um
yeah you
[Music]
wait this girl we have someone who's on
90 Day Fiance calling in what's her name
send me a picture of her
no she's not on it she was contacted by
people from this man has a micro penis
oh we just we just I think I just talked
to somebody who had a micropenis thing
going on let's talk to loveberry sure
it says here uh pronoun she her oh
okay so it's a is it a trans person
I don't know is loveberry what they call
their tiny micro penis
is that why they're called loveberry
[Music]
the keemstar must be seething that we
appropriated his sound bite
have you ever have you ever met keemstar
yeah what like when you what's it like
when you guys are like looking at at
each other in the eyes well
the conflict began many years ago when
he came on the podcast we had him on it
was fine and then when he left
he started having like a uh
narcissistic rage or something I don't
know how what some kind of pathological
thing where where the some of my fans
were angry that he came on the show and
I said something to the effect of like I
get it you know I also I also hate him
which was strongly worded I apologize to
him for that actually at the time thank
you baby I love you I love you too Bubba
and uh but I said I think it's important
to have conversations with people that
have different perspectives than us sure
yeah and that comment set off a chain
reaction uh that has yet
to be resolved you feel like you're
getting like jostled in 5 000 different
directions by all the different opinions
on what you should and shouldn't be
doing at all times
oh for sure yeah I mean it's confusing
but after a certain amount of time you
kind of just
um
you kind of just gotta trust your the
walking path you know yeah are you are
you good at like following your own
intuition with these things you gotta
become I've become pretty good at it
yeah I mean it's tough yeah I do get in
trouble a lot though um
wait whatever happened was that
micropenis a fake call no I was waiting
until you wrapped up this conversation
to bring them in yeah yeah
all right uh you ready I just saw you
said dude wanted to call in and
responded with death to all Jews uh
those were sent five minutes apart
his audience
to go to my Twitter and tweet at me
death to all Jews is he Jewish
no no
keemstar hates the Jews would say he's
then Jew if you will yeah four four four
yeah on the spectrum of course yeah
what was um I I feel like I asked you
this last time what was the theme of
your Obama
so my bar mitzvah was unorthodox I
decided I didn't want to do the
traditional thing I took all my best
friends to Disneyland that said it was
awesome I did a similar night I
had mine at Dave and Buster's oh that's
fire yeah we had like loaded up uh Dave
and Busters
yeah it was great it was a great day so
shout out to my mom for that was the
Torah portion also at Dave and Buster's
yeah yeah we did uh it was a good Vitara
and then we played Dance Dance
Revolution
what a day
yeah they should I wonder if they ever
have a Nagila dance dance track that'd
be sick this would be sick
you got to put your hands up it can
track your hands
someone someone get working on that all
right let's talk to the
let's talk to dingleberry
love Barry loveberry
love Barry one second
I love Barry are you there
what's crazy is like I'll go back to
synagogue every once in a while for like
a whatever thing and then I re fully
remember all of the hymns it just comes
like it's imprinted yeah interesting I
didn't even know you were Jewish
[Applause]
I know people too high up people who are
Jewish they'll help you out with
anything brother sick that's how it
works that's just how it works when
you're a Jew it's beautiful all right
it's beautiful is Dingle here
okay uh sorry I'm making jokes but your
name is loveberry right
yeah my real name is Angel though I
don't mind sharing it so it's Angel yes
sir and Angel do you prefer loveberry or
angel
you can use angel I like my name Angel
so are you are you trans
no so I um met this guy and oh you have
a micro penis story
that's a huge there's a big difference
there was a word there that I missed but
I'm interested in a micro penis story
actually as well
yeah so
um I was on hinge one day and I saw this
guy that I thought was cute he dressed
nice he seemed funny so I liked him we
talked for like a month you know talking
on the phone doing all that stuff
watching videos together watching movies
together and then one day he came over
to my house and so we're at my house
we're watching some videos on my bed
um I think I'm thinking he's cute so
like I like going for a kiss we're like
kissing for a little bit and then it
like gets a little hot and heavy and
then so I asked if it's okay if I touch
him and he says yes and so whenever I
pull down his pants it is a micropenis
and I didn't have a reaction right there
I just kind of like
jerked him off basically and then like
while that was happening he um called me
bro twice
bro that's my man I call you a bro all
the time but not while she's jerking me
off what was the what was the context of
him calling you bro while you were
jerking him off he was moaning and then
he said oh bro no way
that's awesome so that did that did that
like really
okay well hold on better than if you
said bro bro
I'm having a bruh moment here
you know what coming is uh you know look
to be fair to him coming is a total bro
moment
undeniably so
very true okay so um he didn't warn you
ahead of time uh because I feel like if
you're a guy with a micro penis and this
is a really tough situation to be in
I've expressed my deepest condolences to
these guys out there I think the best
course of action is to give a heads up
hmm you think so I think so because you
don't want to shock Factor the shock
factor is going to be a tough how micro
of the pianists are we talking because
you're saying you're able to jerk them
off so I'm wondering right like are we
using two fingers or are we going with
the whole hand or we have like a little
some tweezers jacket well I don't know
how graphic I can get go ahead but
basically he was kind of a chunky guy
and his um I'm also a chunky girl so
nothing wrong with that but I was like
I when I pulled his pants down it was
already hard and it was basically like
maybe an inch or two so I don't really
know if that qualifies as micro penis I
would say it does yeah I was jerking him
off he had a little bit of a fupa and so
when I was jerking like I felt more of
his penis maybe under the fupa question
mark I really don't know so yeah when
you're a larger guy the penis actually
it can get well I don't know if that it
gets smaller but the fat starts to
consume the base of it so so I got I'm
kind of curious okay so for your calling
in are you attempting like to make sense
of this are you like what
I mean what did you what did you make of
the situation like did you have you
talked to him again
Yeah so basically
after the
so like I jerked him off for a little
bit and after like the second bro I was
pretty much like my hands getting tired
I'm not gonna do this anymore
and then he was like oh yeah for sure
and then I don't know like I I'm the
type of person who's like really open
and honest so I don't know why I did
this but I was like my uncle's coming
home you have to go and he's like from
like a city over so maybe it was like an
hour drive two hour drive so like
uh when he left I was just like oh what
the is wrong with me and so like we
talked for like three days after that
and then I like ghosted and I feel so
like really really bad and I've been
like thinking about it like every single
day since it's happened
I just feel like I'm guilty because like
I feel like it's a really superficial
reason yeah this one well was it the bro
or the micro penis or a combination
it was a combination but also he had
like uh he was really religious he had
just like come out of like Jehovah's
Witness so like he had been like being
out of that and like when he had
foreskin I didn't mention this part
because we got a little far but when his
foreskin like wouldn't come down tight
foreskin I've heard it like crusted with
and like kind of stuck I don't know
I like it looks like it looked like you
would like put your head into a
turtleneck and like like fortunately
yeah you'd be surprised how many people
I've talked to and met who have super
tight foreskin and people always go
there's a big I would be surprised at
that I hear it all the time now I see
and I'm saying people always coming out
against circumcision has become like a
big talking point really to to consider
um circumcision genital mutilation but I
will say and listen that might be true
um however
getting circumcised as a man with tight
foreskin like when a baby gets
circumcised when my son's got
circumcised it literally takes five
minutes and they heal in like two days
but I'll tell you I know people who got
circumcised as adults for type foreskin
and that will change your life for
the worse bro why do you not the same
you're circumcised you are not the same
man yes I am how do you feel like that's
negatively impacted your life not at all
Jewish now I'm happily circumcised
that's why I find it funny when people
are trying to tell me that
my genitals are mutilated I I don't feel
that my genitals are mutually isn't
circumcision isn't that literally
mutilating a general
yeah but I think the term genital
mutilation which I think first came to
arise when you're talking about like
women in the Islamic world who are that
very uh uh
who get their you know clitoris or the
vagina circumcised which is essentially
them removing their trying to stop them
from having pleasure from sex so when
you compare to something like that I I
I'm going to disagree what did I say
okay
that's just for safety for myself ignore
me
I feel like doesn't doesn't being
circumcised like make it yeah I was more
sensitive
um you must be circumcised oh yeah yeah
well so apparently no apparently the the
foreskin has
a great number of of of uh nerves in it
okay
yeah
it's you said that uh you know a lot of
it's you know what I think it's a
beautiful thing
that you have so many close connections
in your life I swear to God I do that
they'll be willing to tell you about the
the circumstances of their foreskin
but there are a lot of men actually and
I will say this who are who are like I
regret or I resent that my parents made
that decision for me and I wish that I
had my foreskin so to them I think your
grievance is valid I saw I remember a
time when I saw like a uh guys I was
watching Like a Porn thing and I saw a
guy's uh foreskin completely envelop his
penis and I do I didn't know at the time
that all penises don't look like that
that's a that's a that's a young Jewish
boy rite of passage I just realizing not
everyone's penis the first time I saw
uncircumcised penis it must have been a
porn or something too I was like
that dude
has that dude's wrong with it is
mutilated yeah like he has some weird
right that that if you're like yeah it
looks like a worm or something I was
like that and my head was was mutilation
hey are you still there
yes I am yes
so I here's I'm gonna say this I
understand why you did what you did
because you want to be honest but like
it's hard like at what point like you
don't want to be like hey I don't want
to talk anymore because you have a small
penis because you don't want to hurt his
feelings but also you don't want to talk
to him anymore and you don't have to so
I mean what what part of this are you
feeling the most guilty about
and just like I know that if like
someone did this to me I would like I
don't like being ghosted I don't ghost
people that's not something I do okay
and I like obviously like it isn't like
a problem like he it's not his fault
that that happened
it's like I don't know I feel like
I'm just like putting too much on him
like
and I'm not doing enough like maybe I
should have said something maybe I
should have just been like hey I don't
think it's gonna work out how long ago
so that was in November but he texted me
most recently on New Year's so he's like
texted me a few times since then and I
just I I I get what she's feeling bad
about like you're you know you're
confronted with the
okay yeah I get it you know but it's
hard that's why I feel like he should
have warned you ahead of time and it's
it's just horrible having a micropenis
is generally just it's so I feel so
sorry because you're it's just it's not
a good conversation it's like having I
mean it's almost like having
foreign
I was gonna say like it's like having
full-blown eggs bro
because you gotta say something you
gotta be like okay yeah you gotta be
like baby I listen before we get freaky
I gotta tell you I have full-blown super
AIDS well he may you know what it's also
a possibility he might not know
that he has a micropenis he knows he
might not know this man's been watching
porn since he was eight years old like
the rest of us
he has spent a lifetime of
having giant hogs in his face well she
said uh he was Jehovah's Witness so if
he was oh he might not know he has a
micro penis yeah okay hold on let's
let's let's I want to keep probing much
like you probing for his tiny penis now
you're so faster than Zach it is very
impressive now um loveberry first I want
the details
were you able to hold the whole thing in
your hand or were you jerking with two
fingers
genuinely curious
so I'm like 4 10 I have pretty small
hands so it fit in my hand okay
and it did it pop out the top of your
hand or was it contained in your fist it
was contained wow was was there was it
just jerking off or was there
was there any was there any like oral
sex or it just kind of ended like that
kiss for a while and then that happened
but I was on my period so I told them
that we wouldn't do anything to me so we
would have had sex or anything either
way
I gotta say they're asking like giving
if like blowing a guy with a micropenis
there is something like r slash oddly
satisfying about just you can put the
whole thing in yeah
there's certainly be no problem by the
sound of that
um I understand that why you're you feel
I I think the for this particular
instance it I think the window is past
you you like if you take a few months
ago you know what no I mean you don't
want to text him back and be like hey
sorry because no no I actually gonna
disagree with you go for it men are
we are at General pathetic
we have no we don't care you know what I
mean like I'll take a you know I mean oh
I'm married but like I'm sure he'd take
her back and here's what I'm thinking my
question for you
Is This Love Barry do you have feelings
for this guy are you still interested in
him
I remember like honestly I have a pretty
bad memory and I talk to a lot of people
and I go on a lot of dates
so I remember him being really funny I
remember him dressing really nice but I
don't I wouldn't say I had I have
feelings for him it's more just like in
the back of my mind where I'm like
thinking about it all the time like just
the way I reacted it's like not mean
well then you know actually I I retract
my I think it wouldn't be a horrible
thing to be like hey you know let's be
friends if only if you actually want to
be friends or not even to be friends but
like maybe just if you feel so bad just
say you know hey I wanted
it's awkward right but just say what
would you say if you could say something
to him I'd like to know that's a good
question me yeah like I would say hey
I'm really sorry for the way I reacted
whenever we hung out really like it I
think it was really terrible like that
the person I want to be and change like
what I did and then he says he says to
you I don't what are why did you leave
he'll says why why did you why did you
make me leave
he says he I don't understand why you
did that what do you say it was so fast
I I would say I know this is probably
not the best thing to hear and wouldn't
sound the best coming from me but I just
don't think we would work sexually
yeah maybe it's better you don't reach
out to him you're just gonna have to
swallow your guild on that one girl yeah
don't don't say that it's hard to it's
hard to uh kind of like gauge just how
honest because I I like I guess you have
to wonder like when you're saying hey uh
you have a you know I mean you don't
have to say right the way you phrased it
we don't work out sexually like who are
you serving by sending that yeah
bad idea
yeah well
um
what is an ideal length
I in my opinion my personal opinion at
least
five to six inches
that's not greedy you know it's not
created you know it's good to know that
that's why you that's why we go on dates
we're slowly building up you know our
ideas of what's what's important to us
well you know most men are uh at least
in America well within five I believe
yeah oh you'll you'll find mind
yeah some something but it's part well
what I was thinking is it's possible
that this man he has this micro penis
and he knows this is an issue
um you are on your period so that kind
of resolves my second part but he could
be just like a demon when he
goes down on you in a good way
that could be true but also he told me
that that was his first time doing
anything with anyone ever okay so
he he's got a rough life ahead of him
I'm not gonna lie this man has a lot to
learn and he's got he's going to have to
cross a lot of bridges
this is this man has a path to walk
yes
and I hope he walks it
he's got no choice yeah well here's the
uh so I wouldn't feel too guilty because
here's the is the the alternative of
like not cutting things off is now two
people are in a thing where you'd have
to explain that too you have to explain
it to him cut them off he's
he's gonna eat that also got him
eventually you know what I mean but I
feel so bad for this poor guy but
honestly I wouldn't blame being too hard
on yourself because like listen this is
gonna happen to him and it's gonna keep
happening to him so this dude whoever he
is he's gonna have to learn how to
approach sexual encounters in a way that
is comfortable for him and his partner
it shocked you right you didn't expect
that so
um I wouldn't be too hard on yourself
you know what I mean and anyway you
jerked him off so he's probably stoked
that's true very true he called you bro
twice dude
I know he loved it so
yeah I'll just take that as I can
is there anything is there anything else
you want to say to the people of the
computer before we go
[Music]
um
I love Olivia and Sam and Lena Love
women we love women all women women love
women here on the show folks don't we we
love women folks
[Applause]
love them very much yeah that was a good
that was a good story though I
appreciate you sharing that
and don't feel too bad don't feel too I
don't know yourself yeah you're okay
this is the tough it's a tough situation
you know what I mean it's it's it's fine
you
you panicked you were shocked by it I
get it yes thank you for getting it it's
his fault for having a tiny
penis all right thank you so much Angel
bye
it's not your fault I always say this
when people think I'm being silly having
a micro penis has got to be one of the
worst you said it was like AIDS
super AIDS terminal uncurable super AIDS
bro yeah would you rat would you rather
have AIDS or a microphone I'd rather
have a micropenis yeah I don't want to
be dying but yeah like in terms of like
non-terminal diseases this has got to be
one of the the toughest to work through
as a guy so would you rather have a
micro penis or really really small hands
well I already I didn't make that choice
but I already have but that's my life I
have tiny hands
yeah do they notice that Lyle were you
purposely pointing that out well your
hand we we've kind of
um uh how did you say that bro why did I
say that yeah I think Ethan I think your
hands are of wait can we
I generally don't do this but here I'll
do it for you
they're the same they're they're
practically the same as mine
[Music]
I don't like to talk about my hands
keep your hands off my car
this is out in the open it's not a
surprise to anyone like we all know I
wear gloves on my face your hands are to
all of us yeah I wear gloves it's
oversized gloves I'm trying really I'm
really thinking about this micro penis
thing and what this guy is gonna I think
it's I I think that it'll be because
he's good it's gonna keep happening he's
going to wonder like I figured out he's
gonna wonder why and it would be nice to
have somebody tell him why but also I
don't know
he's going to figure it out he's going
to figure it out not her problem you
know what I mean there's more to life
than
you know having a micro penis I think
angel
a I get why she's felt guilty but you
know she
she may have been shocked but she still
did the ACT you know right still touched
his penis yeah that was pretty good from
his perspective he was probably stoked
girl he was he was broke I'll say this
if uh if if the devil came down and was
like you must open this box and inside
is a life where you have a small penis
uh and then or it could be a life where
you have AIDS if I opened the box and it
was a small penis life I'd be I'd be
stoked I'd be like hell yeah well you
can now live with AIDS pretty much for
yeah indefinitely it's cool to have any
kind of a life even one with a small
penis no I would I would take a micro
penis over a terminal illness for sure
you know
I want to live damn it
but uh I love you too Jeremy I I
genuinely think there's probably some
dudes who would choose to die probably I
genuinely think that and uh I'm not
kidding
bro jobs Hazel says she's giving out bro
jobs they're so good
bro let's keep it on so thank you
loveberry that was a nice call thank you
very much you want to pick the next one
I'm gonna go to the actually I'm gonna
run to the bathroom I need the bathroom
I'm cool you want to pick one out mom
yeah sure I'm right back okay let me let
me look
how's it going Chad how you guys doing
all right let's see we got going on here
[Music]
you're doing great man
he doesn't need your reassurance maybe
like in a chat I know but he's a
professional he's professional but you
know he's he's not on his own thanks I
mean that's true a positive
reinforcement you know what Dan we're
boys all right I don't I don't need you
telling me that I need to assure him you
and Lila boys yeah we we hung out I mean
what well no I just saw my twitchcon I
said hello but uh Lyle and I are boys
why look at us a couple of former Adult
Swim interns here oh yes talking about
micro penises look how far we've come I
know I know life is life is crazy this
feels like a nice full circle moment
yeah still live streaming
um man these are all these are all tough
baby
chocolates oh thanks dude
um that was another cancer one Dan
you're doing great too oh thanks cam I'm
not sure what you're gonna get I thought
are you able to see the highlights like
me highlighting this right here uh hold
on oh yep let's talk to Alex that's yeah
that's a good highlight that's
highlighted that one that's a good
highlight yeah me that I I was looking
at that one earlier yeah let's talk to
Alex all right let me grab Alex one
second Beautiful
all right we're gonna move
Australian tour dates they're coming
soon
move to
the room Cameron you're doing Alex are
you uh are you there doing great
hello Hello Alex
yeah hi hi Alex how are you it's how's
life
I'm I'm great how are you uh I'm a gecko
on the computer hey Alex you're doing
great man
uh thanks thanks Ken how how can we get
you today Alex
um all right so
yeah my story is about how
um
basically
uh
I've always kind of been very good at
gaming the system as far as school goes
um I'm in college now but um ever since
like middle school I have been I've
gotten very good at like
cheating on homework basically yeah
okay
and how has that worked out for you as
you ventured into your adult life
yeah exactly so now I'm in junior year
of college and um
the workout hard
and my work ethic is kind of shot and
uh yeah so you know I'm now I'm trying
to like re-teach myself how to be a good
student
well all right let me ask you this what
are you going to college for
software engineering do you care about
software engineering
no okay so you're trying to get really
good at a thing that you don't care
about
yeah yeah I mean I'm decent at it and
it's
one of the few jobs that I don't hate
doing okay what do you what do you let
do you like doing anything or is all is
is life bleak
no life's not Bleak um I just don't like
working really Amen brother
um could you find uh uh we were talking
about this earlier could you find
um somebody to uh get married to and you
can be a stay-at-home father and not
have to do anything I guess that would
no that's doing it's doing stuff but
it's different it's you're you you
probably
listen I hated having a day job too I
knew that I would never be happy doing
that and that's part of what pushed me
into the career I am today to to do that
it's about you know the freedom it's
about not having to be somewhere you
don't want to be it's about not having a
boss it's about not being forced to sit
and do meaningless dumb desk
work and sucking out and then like
counting the minutes of your
life draining away as you look
desperately at a Excel file to
do God the most meaningless menial
dog task to make a bunch of
rich people richer it's just like so
pointless this cannot be the reason
we're here on Earth you know down is
desk work
because we're at a desk yeah I think I
think that counts yeah
um okay have you thought about I think
about this all the time have you thought
about
um working long enough to save up a
little bit of money and then running
away to a lower cost of living country
where you can uh rent an apartment for a
tenth of the price as you could in
America and um just kind of sitting
there that was my point to be honest I
was like all the time yeah yeah I was
like I could probably retire in
Vietnam yeah
yeah that's a good plan B
um my girlfriend lives in the UK so
that's that's expensive not that not
that much cheaper than America yeah but
um
I'm also very bad at saving money that's
another way what do you spend money on
um
I I order a lot of takeout you know
ubereats doordash it's expensive bro
that is like 50 bucks yeah boy it
adds up
50 bucks for Taco Bell oh let's all
right let's get let me all right let's
get into the issue I missed you you
cheated and now you feel like you
up yeah
yeah pretty much yeah I cheated my way
through high school and well so what I
mean well okay well but here's the thing
you learned a skill
which is cheating
yeah yeah and I mean I don't know so how
can you now how you could how can you
now like that's what your that could be
your profession use that can you cheat
more in a positive direction like can
you cheat the system use that
become a con man well so here's a
suggestion to you I've heard of this
before where like programmers or or
you're doing some kind of like Tech job
like that you can Outsource it to some
people in India oh yeah
to do the work for you that's
but then that's cheating and then the
people from India they Outsource it to
people in Houston and it just becomes a
big you know ping-pong Houston those
poor Houston Knights
they're desperate as what is this
Alex Alex tell us just I want to what's
your dream life you could wave a magic
wands you doing any what are you doing
my dream life yeah uh I guess
realistically I have to work so no
outside of real you could there could be
unicorns in it whatever you want
forget about the realm no work Society
no work
um
I I live with my girlfriend and
um listen Alex I gotta get out of this
I'm sorry
love you though
oh yeah you're good bro just keep
crushing cheat your way out of it you
could cheat out of anything
all right then keep it up man don't lose
don't lose Faith sorry bro I just I felt
it what are you what do you what's like
what's your dream call for this moment
oh well well we had no like the
micropenis one was great okay I wanted
to talk the one that I like is when you
have deep interpersonal
conflict okay with with uh somebody like
that that to me usually gets me down
under measure of a good this one I
really wanted to talk to this girl who
wanted to do porn but her boyfriend was
again like that sounded really
interesting to me
I think anything could be interesting
but that was like that was that was a
path to nowhere how so
he's 21. yeah he doesn't like working
sure
also he wasn't very forthcoming it
started going circular a little bit I've
got like two but it's like he's 21 he
doesn't like working it's like well you
know
I get it he couldn't answer your
questions you're asking what's your
dream uh where life he's he's hesitating
too much okay we need
motion sure we need
I need well sometimes wow well in the
moments of hesitation they're thinking
that's the whole that's the point of
talking about this stuff my sense was
that as much as I love him yeah he's a
fan of the show and I love that sure
it just wasn't going anywhere
interesting bro sure sure I I it wasn't
man I'm sorry you guys want to do a poll
I like that let's do a poll now I like
that I want to see I thought about doing
the same I've thought about letting the
Chatters decide when I keep talking to a
caller but then but they're gonna do
that but they're gonna next ever they're
gonna next I'll like pick up a phone
call and somebody's like hi my name and
it's just next yeah sometimes I'm deep
into a call in the CH and I'm seeing a
chat like move on but I'm like hell no
right but you can't I I used to read the
chat while I do the phone calls but then
they're like this guy and I'm in my
head I'm like oh well maybe I should
hate this but no I don't want them in my
head you're right you gotta you gotta
sometimes anyway let's read chat so I
was just saying can you guys vote I'd
like to know if I was right in that one
because I had stepped out to go to the
bathroom you you hung up on the caller
so I said we got to move I said we gotta
get out of this there's no wrong or
right subjective
well no we're going to get to the bottom
of this right now okay we are the people
sure
was Ethan right to move on from the
caller yes or no yeah but you know you
don't want to let the people look my
Prime objective is to entertain the
people yeah of course I'm not actually
here to uh
what is your what do you what do you
want out of if you died tomorrow yeah
would you be like we did it or would you
be like nah I still had things I wanted
to do
I did it you did it yeah okay it starts
around bonus mode now I'm on bonus mode
for sure I'm just enjoying my family
yeah I'm enjoying working with all these
wonderful people I'm enjoying um
entertaining all these awesome people at
home yeah I feel like totally blessed
I'm right where I want to be and uh I
don't want to die do you get a sense
from them that they're like Ethan has to
do something right now or else I'm unsub
unfollowed no yeah
why is everybody saying bad Paul I mean
is it that's a good straightforward pull
thank you thank you for saying so Ethan
so that one was actually closer than the
last one yeah
yeah but not as much support on this one
I'm afraid I'm sorry guys I didn't know
what this is
what's uh what do you what what gets you
out of bed in the morning Ethan
[Music]
he doesn't
he did phone calls saying where are you
pretty much nothing what gets me out of
the bed in the morning is
I'm not that depressed I find that
question kind of odd it's like what make
what keeps you from literally swallowing
a bottle of Advil that's a legitimate
question there's a lot of things I enjoy
in the day I love being with my kids I
love doing this show I love making
dinner spending time with my fam it's a
well-rounded life I like playing video
games I like watching anime
um I I there's a lot there's a lot
throughout my whole day you know there's
things I enjoy that's good that's a
that's as far
better well-rounded life than I have
pizza we'll keep what gets you out of
bed in the day the Sun
so there you go stop the Sun from being
why haven't you killed yourself yet
that's why haven't I killed myself yet
well because
um
it's an interesting thing right because
we're you're gonna die anyway just cut
to the chase
I'm not ah you know I mean there's stuff
there's you know
have you ever had nerds gummy clusters
so good those stop me so good
bro legit so good they can have this as
a free advertisement nerds gummy clubs
saving lives stop me
from violently committing suicide
you guys know that they recently started
selling Sour Patch Kids but only the
blue ones well look at why
because the blue ones are the best
I thought they all taste the same Ethan
absolutely not Ethan okay I would run
away before I killed myself you know
like I would there's so many um like you
can go Rogue you can go to
like I think the idea of trying to start
a new life in a totally foreign place
you can just Fascinate yeah you can just
re-roll you respawn respawn
yeah rewind time it's a rewind time all
right let's see what else we got help
we've been going for a minute eh yeah
we're coming up on two hours in a few
minutes here oh not bad it doesn't feel
like it's been too far having a lot of
fun out having a lot of fun cruising
okay so this one sounds interesting and
a lot of people can probably relate
collie gang
uh
Culligan 26 number 21 Dan okay I see it
she says her co-workers are making a
huge mess and leaving it for everyone to
claim
um a common office problem yeah but I do
Wonder
how bad it are we talking about and to
what lengths are we going to remedy this
um
we may have lost collie gang okay that's
no problem
um so we have one where they lived in a
religious cult sure
um we have one where
he likes his job but he's getting
screwed on pay
from Cuba living Sweden
how to connect
I can't help you with that
he's getting married and he wants my
advice
10 looks kind of interesting but also
paradoxical she's calling because she
almost got someone in the Discord fired
today by accidentally tattling and voice
chat so now she wants to call into the
life let's make it worse somehow
I'm interested
um okay that's oh there's actually a few
good ones here at the top too one advice
on giving up weed for mental health I
mean yeah stop smoking right
do you have any do you have any vices do
you have anything that you do I have any
vices yeah
well food that is one that I'm always
constantly in battle with no that's
pretty much my advice uh other than that
you know I
that's a big one though right like that
that one really hurts man yeah um what's
your uh what's what's your poison is it
the sweets is it the savories dude
everything yeah I don't really hit sweet
stuff that much for me it's like a
salami sandwich with cheese and
mayonnaise do do you get stoned do you
smoke you don't have that no I don't I
don't smoke weed I don't drink okay you
know I don't do any drugs smoke weed
every day I had a prescription of Xanax
but I was getting too comfortable with
it so I canceled it
yeah I feel that I was just like no
don't I said to the doctor do not
prescribe me Xanax anymore big old
doinks do not renew this I am the doctor
now
yeah
do we have anyone what happened where
are we I was waiting for you to select
one oh unfortunately let's talk to the
weed lady probably had to go weed lady
went weed lady
um
[Music]
this is actually breaking on Newsweek
this week yes Prozac used to help with
depression now actually a psychiatrist
are recommending nerd gummy clusters
looks about oh that'll brighten up your
day breakthrough drugs I will gladly be
in that uh that testing phase
all right uh I do have uh that weed one
would you like to just talk to issy do
let's talk all right yeah I'm not I'm
not sure people find out I'm not a big
fan of weed smoking I think it's so over
hyped by people who are like built their
whole personality around smoking have
you have you ever got a smoked pot oh
yeah yeah
I don't think I heard about that because
he brings it up whenever he can
um how was it I'm sure it's great I
didn't actually feel it I took a small
hit because I was nervous and I didn't
feel it okay well that's why you took a
small too small of a hood I was scared I
was like
because I wanna I didn't want to like
take a hard hit a crack well the thing
about what I could jump in like that
there's some there's got to be something
to it or else so many people wouldn't be
addicted to it it's probably awesome I
hear it is awesome yeah and so I wanted
to get a little taste of it before I
went all the way in so I hit it before
you went oh I thought you were like were
I thought it was like you or were
getting off of drugs and you wanted to
try crack as like a celebratory music
going all in no no no no no no I wanted
to because like I
I didn't want to go full in first with
the hard crack hit in case I didn't like
it so I wanted to do a small you know
hit it small but I guess it was too
small
mm-hmm
like uh like a Costco sample of crack
plus actually but yes that's a good
analogy can we get issy on the phone is
he is in the room is he are you there
I I see you there oh there you are yeah
what is up Queen
hey hey
what's the problem
so I wanted to call in because I'm a
mental health nursing student but I've
recently become quite a big Stoner so
there's sort of like an internal debate
ethically like is that wrong or it's not
unethical at all why do you think yeah
what's what's your take on the ethical
debate a lot of the people I'm working
with have substance abuse issues so do
you drink me
yeah okay like you know occasionally
you smoke more than you drink
at the moment yeah
go ahead you go ahead please what what
um
um so uh uh do you do you have a healthy
relationship with weed
or do you also feel like you're kind of
struggling with it you use it too much
yeah I do
I feel like I mean I love it I smoke
marijuana to beat my wife so I don't
beat my wife and children I've I know
exactly what you mean
my queen marijuana so I don't beat my
wife and children
that's Dana White from the UFC sure
well so so you feel I guess there I
guess the problem is in that you feel
you have a problem that that that's
important
you feel that you smoke too much
at the moment yeah and are you having a
hard time scaling back for example I
think it's totally normal and fine to be
like it's the weekend I'm gonna get high
and then during the week day when I need
to go and work and be sharp I'm not
gonna smoke
yeah I mean don't get me wrong like it's
off the clock but
um I definitely could cut down and I am
trying but it's a tricky one can we dive
first into the this like cognitive
dissonance thing you got going on of
like because I don't know I'm playing
around with this idea in my head about
this right now of that look you're
helping people with an issue that you
have and you're looking at that as a bad
thing but is it possible that your
personal experience with the issue is is
informing you in a positive way as
you're helping other people with the
same thing
yeah completely like I think yeah to an
extent like it really can help to have
it personal experience like when you're
doing nursing but it's just where that
line like well hold on I don't get the
feeling that you're like this degenerate
yeah yeah
no I don't think so
can I ask uh this I don't know this is a
hip-hop thing but like is there a
recurring substance that most of the
people you work with are are are into
uh it depends a lot of them have had
like weed abuse issues and then a lot
like
um a lot a lot of different
different issues are you high right now
um
they comment
it's okay
so let me ask you this if they drug test
you will you get fired if you have THC
in your blood
but I don't know if this is true and I
feel like I shouldn't take this
as like the truth but an Uber driver
told me once stop right there
the NHS can't legally like randomly drug
tested
driver told you that rest assured it's
true well I'm yeah you're good
well no that should actually be really
easy to research but if you're still in
school so are you getting good grades
yeah I mean I may give away from
graduating so my grades are good
but you have to have a certain amount of
practice hours and I feel like weed has
made me more lazy than I really am well
look if you're working with um people
addicted to the drugs I mean smoking
drugs is could be practice she's on
shoes boots on the ground your boots on
the ground
practical experience yeah on the ground
I'm getting in fact I would go as far as
say you can actually write off your weed
on your tank
you're researching
well if you feel it makes you lazy
so this is what happened with my
experience with weed I was smoking and
smoking and smoking and then I started
to realize like all these negative
consequences that I was doing of it and
my problem with it was that I was in a
Social Circle where everyone was smoking
all the time and it was extremely hard
for me to pass on it
and so there was that angle and then the
other angles I started to realize like
oh I'm getting lazy I'm getting
forgetful I'm getting because I wasn't
you know I was I went from nothing to
like fat bong grips
so it wasn't like a subtle like let's
just share a spliff like I would get
blitzed out of my mind so I would say to
you isim if you are having these
feelings that weed is negatively
affecting your life for example making
you lazy you do not want to feel lazy
when you're 19 on the verge of entering
your profession for your life so that
feeling is going to continue to fester
and you want to get on top of that now
before it becomes a real issue so my
advice to you is to
I think it's I think it is serious I
think I think it's you got to get on top
of that and you know a lot of people
have really healthy relationships with
weed just like alcohol it turns out the
best research available right now shows
that alcohol is you know far far worse
for your health and uh compared to weed
is is you know uh in the in the tier of
drugs weed is way down on the bottom in
terms of like negative impacts where
alcohol is right there at the top we
drank beer and so I would urge you to
try to find a healthy a healthy pattern
of of weed use because you like it and
that's good it's good to have things you
like and that you look forward to yes do
you think you'd be able to not smoke
during the week and just enjoy it on the
weekend
yeah I mean it's just like that thing
like when you have weeds I'm gonna smoke
it but it's trying to hold off on that
like
I feel like I just need to stop
is there anything that you think you
could uh replace weed with
have you tried opiates have you tried
[Laughter]
I've been playing uh I've been playing
Nintendo switch lately and I've been
I've been playing Super Mario Odyssey
I'm looking at all this stuff and it and
it's it's pretty trippy
yeah I got a steam though you know what
that is I know what that is awesome yeah
I love it
well sounds to me if you cannot control
your consumption of it then I think you
gotta you gotta quit it
very true very true at least for a time
for a period of time where you can kind
of clear your head and get a better
perspective on the situation like if you
stop smoking for a month you're gonna
have a much better perspective on your
relationship with weed but I do think
right now you got to do whatever you can
to get on top of that because obviously
your career and your school is way more
important than just getting high at
night I mean ultimately getting high is
fun but like in 10 years it's you you'll
look back on that and be like you know
it's just dead space yeah you should get
Snoop Dogg in here to do like the
counterpoints
um I wonder what Snoop Dogg would say
nah baby
[Laughter]
well I think Snoop is a high functioning
weed addict there's different types of
weed addicts I think there's some people
I know who can smoke all day every day
and I don't know if it's a matter of
like how much you consume to where it
stops affecting you so much but they are
high functioning now I myself was not a
high functioning Stoner uh smoke weed
every day it's just kind of that's what
he would say yeah
yeah I felt like I functioned quite well
but that's almost a bad thing well by
the way the final thing are you you're
in the UK
yeah is weed legal in the UK what's
going on over there with that
it is not it is not what is happening in
that country what are you all doing the
thing
I think some people can get it medically
but
like not it's quite difficult way more
than in America well the police bust you
for doing that or do they not care
I don't know they don't really give a
yeah unless it's like yeah so it's
decriminalized okay
just put it down man just put those just
put the joint down
two talking geckos telling you to put
the weed down
can I say your green face paint makes
your eyes look so red and it was really
tripping me out for a minute who's mine
are Geck or a Lyles right
I smoke two joints before I go to work
and then I treat the mentally ill
I trip out when the mentally ill talk to
me about their problems I go outside and
then I smoke a joint
this drug addict he says to me I'm
seeing multiple of you and then I go
outside and smoke a joint
smoke smoke
every day
these mentally ill people I just
want to get paid
smoke smoke weed everyday man
I just want to be high every day
bro are you high right now
I go to church and I'm high
I don't understand a thing that pastors
say
[Music]
I go to funerals go ahead take it
and I say to the rabbi God why no did
you make me so high oh my my God why did
you make this weed so good
[Music]
that's yes God why did you make this
weed so good Bond
I went to my mother's funeral I was high
this is not good I barely remember
that day
[Music]
yes yes yes yes
I smoke weed before I get in the car man
and I just arrive at my destination
where the have I been good Smoky
flavor
yes yes yes
smoke every day
yes yes yes yes yes alrighty
thank you thank you so much thank you AC
thank you
I think we hope to
that
you know
she's 19. she'll figure it out
uh let's see Daniel actually a little
update the um call from earlier finally
got back to me oh the porn one uh
talking to boyfriend about wanting to do
points yeah available she messaged me
she's very interested in calling in
let's get it going okay I will uh bring
them in right now stand by
someone's gonna remix that and some
reggaeton bro it's gonna be a Bop
of the century all right um is it Oni
or do you go and energy or Oni if I was
saying the guy uh costume really honors
me
[Music]
yeah
oh there you go wait we have eyes Oni
it's Oni I guess it's awning how's it
going
um it's good I'm sorry I'm very nervous
no don't don't don't be don't be yeah I
just I smoked a bunch of weeds
you heard his song it was like it was
like a siren ball I want to do Port but
my boyfriend says no way
okay wait Oni all right how how are you
doing what's going on
I'm trying to find so how
she's right here we can just ask her
yeah how old are you
where do you live or don't tell me where
you live just tell me what's your social
security number yeah
no so I'm I'm 20.
um yeah I started doing only fans two
years ago literally like right when I
turned 18 because I was like it
like I wasn't feeling like I have much
to live for and so I was like well am I
gonna live long anyway let's do this
um okay have you been successful on only
fans
yeah I've I I've made enough to quit my
job and I worked at a bank like so
that's kind of awesome right because
that that's what the dream in a lot of
ways to be self-employed how much are
you pulling in a month may I ask
Ed any of my
subscriber count
turned off so people don't figure out
who I am so what's the what's the what's
the sort of issue with the boyfriend
okay so the issue with the boyfriend is
um I am at a dilemma of if I should ask
him to do
um like a like a video with me
um because
uh I don't know he said very conflicting
things to me about my only fans so he
thinks it's cool that like I can make my
own money and do like I have plenty of
free time to help him out with just
random that he needs done
um
and
it's just
I don't know and then sometimes he he
talks like weirdly about women he's like
oh yeah all those girls or you know some
type of way and so I'm not really sure
if he's like into the only fans thing or
if he's just down because the money or
what uh have you like have you had like
a conversation with him where he like
expressly
said anything or anything like that
let me ask you this
how long have you guys been together
so were you dating him when you started
the only fans or after
um after after I started the only fans I
started dating him
um it was It was kind of at similar
times but the only fans came first and I
told him about it and he was kind of
like oh I don't know if I want to date
an only fans girl like blah blah blah
and I'm yeah how long how long ago did
he say that
that was at the very beginning of our
relationship and we were sitting in an
IHOP so so it's been so he told you he
didn't he like how but you guys have
been dating for two years yeah so I mean
has this has it been like a a point of
content I mean this is your job so I
assume you're talking about it all the
time I like I assume the nature that you
do only friends is is in your
got you guys it's brought up
yeah it gets brought up but he he always
seems really weird about it like he
doesn't want to see what I'm doing okay
really how does that how does that make
how does his feelings about your only
fans make you feel
well honestly I'm glad that he doesn't
want to see what I'm doing because on
one hand I can see like it's it's weird
for him because it's like for other guys
but at the same time they're just paying
customers so I don't I don't know what
the big deal is I've offered to give him
just like a free account because I I can
do that I mean I do the same thing here
I just don't show my dick you know I
mean I'm out here entertaining people
it's just my dick is in my pants
and we're grateful for that yeah uh let
me uh okay what kind of what kind of
content are you making is it you're just
taking nude pics or are you like
self-pleasuring is it graphic
it's just like
it's like loot
it's like lewd pictures like bikini
pictures and stuff because you know I
know I have the vibe like Oh I'm a young
girl I don't know what I'm doing and I
got like a ton of people like in
the first month I started and it was it
blew my mind
I have
um a tick tock and
um one day like I was just digging
around after high school and I started
posting on Tick Tock this was like right
when Cove had started so I had too much
time and at some point I had 10 000
followers and I was like oh my God
that's mind-blowing like I'm sure
everybody knows that type of feeling so
then I decided to start the only fans
and I put it in my Tick Tock bio don't
do that yeah anybody's watching do not
do that well look is look is it a night
is it I would it be ideal if he was into
the only fans or you prefer to just have
your like separate universes
separate universes but I don't want to
hurt him in any way by not including him
in everything in case that's what he
wants but he hasn't expressed any like I
don't know he has
he he just seems to have weird opinions
on women who do stuff that I do but at
the same time he's a very nice guy like
he's perfect he's got a great dick it
would look good on camera but yeah
so the issue is is not about like oh
this only fans thing is is a is a point
of contention in our relationship it's
just about whether or not you want to
get him to show his dick on camera
yeah a little bit hold on
when you say you want to start doing
porn
I don't mean with other people just him
um yeah just just him he doesn't have to
show his face because obviously in like
most modern stuff nobody wants to see
the guy's face anyways like I can say
that I'm a girl I watch a lot of gay
stuff let me just but
besides the point
um he I told him that I was gonna
unblock the state that we lived in and
he didn't seem to like that which that
that's like he's embarrassed he's
embarrassed he doesn't want people to
know that his girlfriend does all his
family yeah and do people know has
anybody connected the dots with who you
are and what you do in your life um no
actually I'm pretty open about it with
like my friends and stuff like my my
family doesn't know except for my
brother and my brother clowns on me
quite a bit for it but that's you know
that's what brothers do and do you think
that you would be making substantially
more money if you included your
boyfriend and something like that
um
requests for like you know some sloppy
toppy vids
um what'd you say
yeah do you currently do sloppy toppy on
like a fake one well I've had that
request too but that doesn't feel right
you're not going to get the same energy
from the real thing you know you need
the awesome it'll be worth a try though
yeah I guess it could I mean I'm just
giving you advice because I my opinion
is that my opinion is that this guy
is not going to want to do this with you
based on what you're saying in fact
yeah that that's just my prediction here
yeah yeah uh it doesn't sound like he's
going to I mean I mean look if you guys
have a close enough relationship I mean
ask I guess you know you know go for it
but uh I don't know I'm I'm still stuck
on stuck on this whole thing of like it
sounds like he
I mean I don't know I I don't know this
guy but it sounds like he has like a a
problem with what you do then that is a
weird like contentious point and I'm
still trying to wrap my head around that
because I mean you guys have been going
on for two years and you sound like
you're happy with him and the one
important thing I do want to say is that
he knew what you did from the very first
day you guys started dating this isn't
something you foisted on him yeah he
knew this going in
yeah yeah I think because in the
beginning of me doing only fans it was
only like you know cute little lingerie
photos and then I gradually started to
expand and I like I would send him
pictures and stuff of what I was doing
so they didn't feel left out you know
um and now I'm worried that if I take
like another big step like even if
that's doing like
I don't know more graphic content
um I'm worried if that would be an even
bigger issue for him because I have
bigger goals for where I want to get in
life and I know what's going to get me
the most money but at the same time I
love this guy but I don't yeah I'm I'm
just at a loss you know
obviously
you got to talk to him about all this I
think you really got to just ask him
like do you approve of what I do for
work right I feel like there's like so
much so much just like a bubbling and
it's like just can we have the
conversation of like hey what's going on
you're saying all these things about it
people who do only fans but like yeah I
mean if you guys had a in-depth
conversation about this stuff because it
seems like it's just like bubbling in
the background
yeah
yeah yeah what have you had the
conversation
no no no no there's just a lot bubbling
so you gotta bring it to the surface you
have never asked him do you do you
respect what do you think about my
profession or you know what I mean you
never asked him that I've never asked
him that but I've asked like hey what do
you think about me posting something
like this this and he tries to give me
his opinion but he leaves it more of to
like
um if I wanted to post a a nude
um I'd be like hey what do you think of
this do you think I should post it and
um it's just he would he would give me
like his body language would say no but
his like words would say so I think he's
uncomfortable with it but his words are
telling me the opposite and I don't know
what to do well you I mean I think
there's so much like assuming going on
we're talking about his body language
like you I mean you've been dating the
guy for two years you know you just have
a conversation about it
I'm nuts here's what you got to
do
ask him do you respect my profession
let's just figure it out yeah and then
ask him if he says no sorry I've
actually my mouth
love that add ice in my mouth oh okay if
he says no Then you kind of have a
problem you guys got to work out if he
says yes then you can move on to the
plan b
can I suck your dick on camera
what does he do
and and he I'm assuming there's gonna be
a nice little bit of money in that for
him potentially too
yeah that's the other thing like if I
did get that far I'm not even sure what
I would compensate him I'm not sure how
to split that divide and I don't want to
end up in like a five percent
um issue yeah yeah yeah yeah what what
is what does he do for a living he takes
up five percent
how the did you do that so fast
yeah he's sick yeah he's actually great
but
um yeah no my boyfriend he he has a
normal job I'm not going to have too
many details does he make a lot of money
what's his income
it's great he has good
arms though which is good for him my
guys what's he doing like 50 60 000 what
what range are we in uh so his current
job is probably like
35 but then he has some property that he
rents yeah yeah so it's a property that
he rents he's good he makes probably
like 60.
so he's a landlord he's a landlord
two two controversial uh occupations
wait hold on hold on how did he afford
to buy an apartment with that income
um he
he just got lucky I don't know he didn't
do a whole lot in his 20s and he just
saved like a bunch of money up and it's
like in the very past few years that
he's um yeah I mean he's already
people over you're just not doing it on
camera
who is this
so but I guess my point this is
interesting so he makes about 35k you
probably based on what I understand of
of how well you're doing could easily
compensate him that much for for
participating in your videos
yeah
yeah would you pay him something like 10
000 a month or is that too much for you
I would love to do that honestly
like I want to take care of this man but
I feel like it comes off like real weird
sometimes
just tell them bro because this man is
making
35 000 a year sure if you approach him
like I want to pay you ten thousand
dollars a month right if he looks sees
it as a business all you got to do is
you know
participate let me suck your dick yeah
like and then and then maybe he can set
some ground rules like I don't want to
do this I can do this he can cover his
face and all this to me
I mean listen that sounds pretty dope
nobody come for him in the comments okay
I made this decision I went after this
man he's 32. and and you're 20. yeah
that I'm sorry but this guy's a 32 year
old dating an only fans model and then
like being secretly judgmented he makes
35k a year landlord dude this guy's a
this guy is going nowhere what what
what or what attracted you to him what
what is what is keeping you wanting to
be in the relationship
well no no so he has his job and then he
has his rental property and I know we
hate landlords but I he takes
care of his tenants that's just a joke
I'm sure he's you can be a good landlord
it's 800 a month per unit like it's
nothing crazy but well let me ask you
this let's say you guys had this
conversation where you asked him if you
know do you do you respect my profession
and you kind of got to the bottom of the
things that you wanted to get to the
bottom too uh is there something that he
could say or or information he could
reveal about how he feels about you that
that would change your opinion on the
relationship
um honestly I think it's going to be if
he doesn't respect what I do that's
probably just gonna have to be it
because I don't want to waste any more
of this man's time he's going to be 40
soon well I think it's 40 32. yeah
that's not yeah I said what I said so is
he going to be 40s tune or is he 32.
eight years is soon 32 is almost 40.
yeah and what world is 32. that's why we
always say you're almost okay you're
almost
42.42 you're basically you feel like
you're almost 30. no no you don't so
stop it Aegis
shame on you
no I feel dead inside but
so are you kind of the are you this the
provider in this relationship sounds
like you make a lot more money than him
when you guys go out to dinner do you
pay
um I I try to pay when I can he pays
when he can't when he
I usually try to pay because we don't we
don't go out a whole lot and when we do
it like it's my little treat would you
order out would you spend money
um yeah we go to restaurants and stuff
we get fun do you you know pay for that
stuff
yeah sometimes we we try to split it
pretty evenly but I don't know as a
percentage as based on a percentage how
often do you pay for it
oh
I'd probably say 50 oh well that's great
the guy then that's that's awesome what
uh what do you like have you ever been
in a relationship before this one
um not really okay
what do you I mean what do you feel like
you're getting out of this arrangement
he's got a nice dick didn't you here
sure I forgot about that
um but honestly let's get real how would
I know
um no previous relationships yeah but he
took your virginity
yeah whoa this is interesting well okay
let me let me put it into perspective
get out Dan is saying get get out I mean
do do what you're gonna do I mean it's
deeply personal but
yeah yeah two years she said how'd you
meet this old guy where'd you meet him
at the hospice
oh oh no I met him I we both
um we both worked at the same restaurant
I met this high school girl that was the
hottest this guy
sucks
what was his role
he was he was my co-worker we had the
same like job title and everything and
like he looks very young for you know
what's her name again
um
look you
you I think uh to be in a relationship
with someone it's a whole thing it's a
large part of your life and you should
be with someone ideally who you know
accepts what you do and is and is okay
with it and I just I look I'm not gonna
tell you what I'm not gonna tell you
what to do none of us can tell you what
to do but just I hope that you're
thinking about these things and whether
or not they serve you and and what
you're kind of getting out of it in
terms of your life listen if my
significant other was doing only fans
primarily I would want to see that what
she's doing because
if you have a good partner
you they're gonna care about what you do
and want to have input for you and be
involved right to encourage you or to
give you feedback to support you so the
fact that he's disin just totally
disinterested to me is a red flag right
and not all endless and not all guys are
suited well suited to be the significant
other of someone who's in your field
just not all guys are well suited for
that you know so I know it's an
unpopular opinion but I think being like
being so young and having a significant
other
I I mean especially I mean you started
dating him when you were 18. yeah I mean
if you had like how well into 18 were
you before you got it okay okay I got
jokes okay well not really jokes
10 days
my birthday is the fifth the 15th yeah
you know that's up you know
that's up right
yeah a little listen man I just I it it
bother like you haven't even had time to
like be alone and look at stuff
[Music]
this man
10 days after your 18th birthday
girl you know that you know that's
up right also you're gonna mature
past him so soon like so true the fact
that he is in the maturity space that
you are or you were when you were that
young so true you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna outage him very soon
and I've it's just it's it's gonna be
like ripping off a Band-Aid because I've
started to like
not build a life because you're right
I'm too young but like I've I've moved
into a house with him like we got a lot
going on and you move you moved it you
moved in with this guy
yeah well hold on did you move into his
place or you went and got a new place
to his place and then he bought a house
and we moved into that how's this
so he's your landlord I
don't understand this is not adding up
this man makes 35k how is he buying
houses
he bought an apartment and now a house
what's going on here
saves his money yes you can save that
much money when you're old as
you're old chill out man well I'm older
than him but I'm not eating I'm not
dating an 18 year old either my wife is
two years younger than me
tell me tell me again what you said you
feel like you're you're getting you're
the victim it's not your fault
that say tell us again what you feel
like you're getting out of the
relationship
feel like I have somebody that I don't
know loves for me and cares in some
aspect for me okay do you like when you
try he practically adopted you when you
think about when you think about like
yourself like do you have a do you have
a good like
self confidence respect image oh do you
have a healthy relationship with
yourself
yeah I have a healthy relationship with
myself
um but I you know probably what put me
in this situation and this is gonna go
into a daddy issue situation you want to
know how old my father is sure
three eight how old is eight
that's pretty wild but your dad's 38.
whoa so he had you when he was 18. so
yeah so wait so he's very close to your
dad's age that is interesting
so you do you like do you like older men
in general or did you just happen to get
involved with this guy
ew I do but lately I've started to think
about it and it's like what if I want to
you know be able to like successfully
grow old with someone to like completion
you know like you know die together
instead of him dying like I don't know
but you're sorry you shouldn't be
thinking right now about who like who
you're gonna die with right now 20 you
got lots of time you're young and you're
rich dude it sounds like um it's awesome
look I like I feel like here's the thing
is nobody can tell you what to do break
up with them
I'm telling you
hey let me ask you this
you live with him are you my grandma you
said that what's your what's your
grandma think about it how would your
grandma uh the the 29.
oh my grandma's 61 and she knows that I
love this podcast she's literally she
thinks I can text you guys like she's
not she's like will you tell Lupine and
Eva this and I'm like oh I love her
what's your what have you what's your
grandma make of this whole situation
well she doesn't know what I do and she
doesn't know about the inner conflict
I'm having because they don't want to
tell her what I'm doing
okay so I have questions so you moved
into his home are you paying him rent
can you hear me
I think he caught your power
foreign
so we can't hear you I don't know if
it's a reception thing or
we could hear you now we can't hear you
can you hear me I can hear you yeah I
want to do pay this guy rent
my airpods died but yeah I paint I pick
you're paying rent
how much by percentage do you pay of the
rent
um well it's like we go in together but
I give him a grand every month and how
much is his mortgage
um
I want to say it's oh
it's 1800. girl you more than
half his mortgage
dude you're paying his mortgage
dude you're literally paying for his
house is your house is your name on that
deed
no no
time to go you're getting paid a little
bit there yeah like how was he just
imagine like if he's okay with you
paying a thousand of a 1800 mortgage I
mean that's pretty slimy
yeah yeah I've got some things to think
about but I'm gonna let you go because
Dan wants to pull the plug no I don't
know
listen if I want it out I would have I
would have no yeah Ethan's the one I
just kind of wanted to know oh you want
to leave oh okay yeah well uh if you
wanna I was gonna ask because you said
you had some things to think about and I
was like okay you I don't it sounds to
me like because you keep what you do
kind of close to your chest like do you
like is this you're one of your first
times kind of talking about this aloud
and then what are you now thinking about
as you have done that
yeah this is definitely the first time
on like such a big click okay
and so I guess before before we go what
do you feel like you have to think about
um I have to think about if my boyfriend
respects my job generally if he respects
me how serious he sees the future with
us okay
yeah because he doesn't really like he's
weird on marriage so listen I don't want
to keep you if you're uncomfortable so
no no no no no I'm not uncomfortable
Ethan I'm not I just I really have to be
like really really really bad okay go
pee go pee oh well I'm waiting for you
if it's just that okay right now why
don't you bring it so bad yeah go pee I
do that too pause to people I'm so sorry
go go go go it's fine go for it you're
good
so this this this is you know what's
interesting is she got yeah sure when
she
brought her boyfriend up she knew it was
a Pandora's Box so she goes don't hate
him but he's 32.
but I feel bad because it seems like she
you know has nobody that she's talking
about it too besides this
private about yeah yeah
um but I don't know it seems like as
she's talking about it she's she's uh
you know thinking about it can you
believe she's paying more than half of
the mortgage I I pretty well
this is maybe reading way too far into
it but my read on that is like his whole
wishy-washiness about like it sounds
like he's not really comfortable with it
at all because he but doesn't want her
to get financially exactly she's he's
mooching off of her so he's not okay
with what she does but he likes the
money that's that's kind of my read on
everything she laid out yeah
but about what a scumbag to stay with
someone you don't respect yeah no it's
not good it's not good I think
I'm back I'm so sorry for a second I
thought I was just watching the podcast
yeah you're high right yeah
so we're gonna we're kind of oh were you
listening to us then if you're watching
yeah so I don't know man you're 20 so
they're just
I think that as time goes on
when this relationship is in the rear
view mirror because I don't I don't
think there's any way this lasts in fact
yeah in fact
I think you'll look back and see just
how up it was it wasn't yeah I I
think yeah dude this that sucks man that
sucks well you say you're just what are
you what are you feeling and thinking um
it's I
I think we've got to the root of this
issue guys I think it's a self-esteem
issue which I know sounds very
contradictory to the like oh my God
but it's like I he nobody's gonna love
me besides him like that you know yeah
we were always that's why I feel like we
were getting at that like you know if
yeah that's why I kept I'm like what are
you what are you getting at what are you
getting out of this what because
obviously you feel like you're getting
something out of it or else you wouldn't
be there so it's like okay what are you
getting out of this and then if we get
to the bottom of that like what's a
better way to look more sustainable
long-term self-involved way of achieving
that without you know but you're
paying disguise why are you so worried
about like being loved is it a daddy I
guess a daddy thing potentially I I
haven't had like a really stable like
home life
um like I moved schools like every year
up until High School like I just haven't
had a whole lot going on for me so it's
like the first person that really showed
serious interest in me and I don't want
to lose that because it was hard to find
well you found it 10 days after turning
18.
as far as time goes I think you've like
got it like almost immediately that is
an excellent point Ethan you know what I
mean like
you sound like a catch
uh-huh you're ever you sound very sweet
I'm sure you're beautiful you're making
a lot of money you know there's guys
lots of guys who will respect what
you're doing and be and love you uh for
who you are forgetting about like guys
for a second I mean if you really feel
like you uh have like a you know nobody
will love me unless if I love myself
then like you know I mean you're only
you're like still walking that path of
getting like internal self validation
and so I mean that's that's more
important than that's way more important
than like finding somebody who will love
you you know
yeah yeah I've um I've been dealing with
like that feeling
um for a long time too and like so I've
been watching the podcast forever and my
one thing was like I want a relationship
like Ethan and Ela because you guys I
don't know you're like yin and yang like
you're all together like you're you're
the perfect couple in my eyes even if
you're not perfect you know
um well we are perfect so I'm gonna stop
there okay all right never mind
correction correct the record yeah okay
but so
well right off the bat if you're if you
want to use my relationship with Ela as
an archetype
I have a ton of respect for what Ela
does and I want to be invested in
everything she does you know what I mean
also there's like a super high level of
communication between us like we know
how we feel about everything yeah so
that that's something important uh that
I think you got to take the lead on just
to figure out like what's really going
on here second of all
I get the feeling you live in a small
town somewhere because I mean you have
an 1800 mortgage for a house right dude
move to a big city girl you got
money you could like get out there
you're young you know what I mean like
life exists outside whatever small town
you're living in and it's awesome it's
exciting yeah there's so much to do and
there's so many cool people to me you
know just just go you know get
out there man we are young I I hate the
idea that you're you know this guy is
like holding you back in some way from
figuring out who you are you know yeah
I don't want to sit down and explain
that to him but I don't want to make him
feel bad but this is a fully grown man
dude
look here's the thing here's the thing
if you don't want to make him feel bad
you don't have like you don't have to
come at this from a place of you
you know this is just you making a
decision with your own life you know it
has nothing even really to do with him
so you know I you don't have to worry
about making him feel bad here's what I
want you to do
thank you
tonight
tell sit down and say I want to have a
conversation how do you feel about what
I what I'm doing uh professionally
that's going to open a Pandora's Box I
think because I I have a bad feeling
he's he's gonna say
also I think it's worth saying you know
listen
oh God this is all so bad you know with
the rent thing I don't know man
tonight
I think you just gotta talk to him but
first of all ask him if he respects you
uh as your yeah as a professional you
know what I mean yeah
how do you feel
um I don't know I feel I feel all right
I'm definitely gonna smoke some more
after this yeah well this took a turn
for you because you just wanted to say
how do I ask him to do porn but actually
the the issues are way way deeper than
that yeah you were right when you said
there was going to be some interpersonal
issues with this one
yeah but um yeah unless you guys have
more questions that's about all I gotta
say is he home right now
no he's at work he's at work
what is where where is at work for him
he he he does
um you don't have to say you don't have
to talk to him he has a day job and he's
okay sorry yeah yeah yeah
um is there anything else that you want
to say before we go really
um no just uh love the show keep up the
good work Ethan please don't get
canceled again I can't promise that do
you want to promote your uh your page
oh
um I I don't know if I want to because I
gave you my government name
um right
so yeah
so let's not do it then yeah yeah no
it's okay all righty girl you're gonna
be fine you're 20. I know everything
feels like it's it's probably Everything
feels so serious and bad uh and it is
right it's serious but uh you're 20
you're young you're making money you got
it all
forget about it huh yeah and you're very
lovable
thank you yeah Olivia says you're
lovable we love Olivia we love you
yeah and if it's any consolation I'm
sure there's at least a few guys out
there who will uh gladly
uh be for you to pay them to suck their
dicks
thank you more than a couple more than a
couple I'd say
seems like an easy sell yeah
all right thank you honey I'm glad we
finally got a hold that was a good one
so thank you Oni yeah it's a tough
situation
God Lee that really opened up when she's
when we found out his age yeah yeah
um it was I I like uh in the club I mean
that was we talked to her for a long
time I really could tell that she meant
it when she said she has some things to
think about
um you know I don't know what sorry
because like you know you can sit here
and be like break up with a break but
she ultimately has to come to that
realization
she's living with him yeah she's been
have two years of life with them it's
it's easy to say
something like that but it's kind of
harder to actually do that we're we've
been going almost for three hours oh
really is there any other ones in here
that you guys think we should jump into
or
uh I think you've looked over it
I think if there were any others
that were really juicy you probably
would have grabbed them already
what's the bottom
these are yeah
she she thinks the company she's working
for might be engaging in tax fraud
that's awesome
actually you know what's interesting you
can report them to the dude this
is crazy the um IRS the IRS has a
program where if you snitch they'll give
you give you money we'll give you a
piece of the action really yes you can
report corporate fraud and they'll
they'll cut you in on it interesting
yeah dude Dan don't get any ideas
Dan's like hmm
so that's what I would think would you
use go check out the IRS they
have like a tip a tip line is that a
weird conflict of interest the
government like paying people to snitch
on each other
I don't think it's a conflict of
interest at all the government wants to
find people who are committing fraud
yeah
and it's worth it for them to because
it's it's really it really is going to
motivate people right yeah if you could
potentially get a lot of money so it's
like I don't see the conflict of
interest
I think the interests are perfectly
aligned
that's why I don't pay taxes
that's my man right yeah I that
taxes are for 80. I mean where are they
gonna Parks I don't go to parks
most of them was burning down uh bombing
uh Iraqi uh playgrounds from uh
10 000 feet up
I am a gecko
well set very good all right I think we
got it yeah but uh how are you how are
you feeling Ethan how's it feel talking
to people about their lives has it has
it made you has it made you think about
your life at all has it made you think
about anything
um
no
all right
but it's been fun I enjoy these types of
conversations and it's nice to talk to
the fans and yeah see how they're doing
it so yeah you do you do call-ins uh
like just regularly right well we there
was a point where we're taking lots of
call-ins and we kind of phased it out
because
there's just there's a risk factor yeah
I'm taking live calls
for sure and it wasn't like that they
were saying obscene things it was just
that they were boring and a lot of they
were boring too many times sure and so
it was the PA it was kind of ruining the
pace of the show sure sure but maybe
with my new policy now where I could say
I gotta get out of this because that's
kind of yeah I mean you can hang up on
them at any time yeah but people get mad
at me sometimes because like someone
will be like they'll call in and they'll
just be like I feel like you're at a
point where you've learned how to deal
with people being mad at you
yeah but I I the one thing that I that
gets me is when the fans are mad at me
sure yeah it's usually other people and
I don't care about that well there's
five five I mean whatever whatever you
do if there's 500 billion people
watching you do it so some of them are
inevitably going to get mad at you for
whatever you do
yeah sometimes they're all mad at me oh
that feels bad yeah they all agree that
I up and that feels bad when that
happens are you like are you like yeah
you're right that's up yeah
usually yeah
they're usually right
in fact I can't think I mean yeah
they're usually right generally
sometimes they take it some people get a
little too serious about stuff
but
that's a good thing they care
yeah I think so it's good to care about
stuff yes although I don't know I feel
like there's there's I feel like there's
a lot of things in there to care about I
think there's a lot of things out there
to care about that don't have to deal
with like you know the computer
oh
uh what do you mean
like I don't know like uh
you know just living in your own
universe
what are you talking about
never mind
we don't care how are you doing I'm
doing all right
um I am let's promote oh promo oh sure
yes I have a podcast
therapy gecko my podcast is called
therapy gecko it's on Apple podcast it's
on Spotify it's you can go to Spotify
search and you take calls you basically
do this I take calls I basically do this
I get into it with people about stuff
and life and things all Anonymous
callers
um I'm going on a big tour right here
guys
uh you can go to
therapygotour.com what is Layla uh it's
Supply you can put links on it oh I see
uh but if an easier way to get there is
if you go to therapy geckotour.com I'm
going all over the place I'm going to
too many places
you know what I typed therapy gecko tour
yeah you can search there because this
thing came up first I bring Folks up on
stage and I talk to them and sometimes
it's exciting sometimes it's uh
surprising sometimes it is boring but it
is always it's always something so you
should come through I'd love to see you
there uh those are my plugs check out
the podcast you're a good man is therapy
gecko a real therapist the support it's
not a licensed therapist I already see a
real gecko you know it would be fire if
you were a real therapist
I thought I thought about it I Googled
it once I Googled it once and I was like
it is so much
easier to be a fake there oh gecko yeah
yeah you probably can't lie about it
either that's probably illegal illegal
if you made like a fake diploma
oh but just part of your ass if somebody
ever tries to uh sue me for pretending
to be a therapist I'm gonna show up in
court in the costume and then they'll
look stupid I think you could make a
fake diploma it's part of the ACT you
don't have paying customers okay if I
made like a clearly fake one in Comic
Sans or so I might you know I might make
a gecko diploma
license
look up how long it takes to make become
a licensed therapist it's too long
you can hear something though here's the
thing you can become a becoming a life
coach this is you bro
North Carolina if it says even for my
therapy gecko then it's obviously a joke
right okay well even for my fake one I
want to I want something better than
North Carolina
but coming to North Carolina September
something
if I wanted to get a license purpose I
want to get
uh maybe y'all should look it up eh
maybe I mean one that maybe who knows I
don't know
no probably I'll probably never do four
years I don't want to go to school I
don't like school you want a PhD or you
want to do grad work I don't want to do
anything undergrad work I want to go on
the video game website and pretend to be
a therapist
if you want to go all the way to
doctoral work that's eight years what
would you be doing if you weren't doing
this
I'd probably be doing some I
don't even know man
I don't know
wouldn't be good no
I don't think so are you happy
I am happy now yeah good what did you
not used to not be happy
I was happy with my life but go I
honestly
going to work and sitting at the desk
was like
[Music]
I don't want to be dramatic because I
know a lot of people do it and I was
going through things with myself just
accepting the fact like this is what
this is just this is life and that's
okay sure but when I would go to work I
would feel
emotionally devastated I'm not even
kidding every every day every day yeah
every day
and I would feel okay when I got home
but I was it was like I don't know I
hated my job it was just like a
normal you know desk job
so there's that what what's making you
happy in life right now
sitting here with you that's sweet
thank you good luck man thanks man tour
you got the podcast we love therapy
gecko you guys I appreciate it
thank you for having me I I said it
already but you know it was uh
uh I remember I went I went straight
from your podcast to like the Grand
Canyon as the gecko and like five people
were like oh you were on the H3 thing
that's awesome yeah
you went straight to the Grand Canyon
yeah I think so as the gecko as the
gecko yes what are you doing the Grand
Canyon I was filming a documentary that
we never finished uh but it was fun just
to go there you should go if you haven't
been to the Grand Canyon beautiful okay
I'm doing a tour I'm I have a podcast
and go check out the Grand Canyon those
are my plans and nice plug no one's
plugged the Grand Canyon yet it deserves
a plan all right y'all so um today's
Monday so tomorrow I'm doing the members
only live see you next Tuesday
and after that is Wednesday we'll be
having a regular episode on Wednesday
right and we got all kinds of fun
Wednesday is a regular app and Friday we
have uh idubbbz Indonesia coming there
you go action-packed
and you know what that means AV is going
to be kicking dad's old stupid ass
correct
soon
all right guys so we'll see you on uh
wait real quick before we go um very
quickly Los Angeles makeup artists were
doing a project if you can send me your
uh profiles just DM me on Instagram
thank you very much wait what what'd you
say uh makeup artist in Los Angeles this
is awesome show me this is kind of more
epic I look so up
because my hair is like all crazy wait
is it getting out my hair
[Music]
is that really the hair color I think
it's just yeah your hair yeah it's very
good it's kind of gold you're actually
like a blonde boy you're literally in
Goblin mode right now dude I hate it
you're in Goblin mode bro no offense but
I hate
this hair color
I'm kind of like you look like an ombre
like what could what color is this like
I I you're
you think it looks bleached I think
you're I think it looks awful is what
I'm trying to say yeah well that's what
are you serious yeah I've been keeping
that kind of low-key this whole time but
either yeah it was really bad this this
round I don't know why I just want it to
be bleach and she put the tone and as
someone with no hair you know I don't
feel right judging your hair color
um I mean I guess I have beard painted
your ear you didn't have to do that you
have to paint it I have never painted my
ears I realized that after I I agree I
agree with Dan it looks like I'm
sorry I love you but it looks yeah I
mean it's nothing against you
it's up and I was not happy with
it at all right and I went through a lot
of pain and suffering to bleach it and I
don't know what the everyone goes
oh the toner why did you bleach your
hair in the first place well just for
funsies but then but then it's good in
the past when you've done it other times
you did it I agree I don't think it
looks bad I just think your natural hair
is nice like a lot of people try to get
that hair so yeah you got great hair you
rock the salt and pepper so I've seen
you have like big Tufts of hair yeah
usually I keep it shorter these days
it was like red undertones this time I
just don't get it like who asked for
copper colored hair or whatever
I just didn't want this at all
so somebody
made it looked like a statues get some
[Laughter]
thanks man
how do you we both have mustaches I was
thinking about I was thinking about that
too I was like I didn't even plan that
yeah me neither how do you usually end
these things
I just leave
hey Geck bless you all
to all a gecknight looks like mud
somebody said
it looks like my hair color I'm just
gonna be honest
I just don't get it I don't get it
either why is this happening to me
I yeah okay anyway we'll see the
members tomorrow thank you to all our
members
and um
and uh everyone else will see on
Wednesday thanks bye guys therapy Gekko
appreciate it I'll see you guys around
the universe
[Music]